EVERYONE WE'RE GOING TO GET
STARTED AS A SUB COMMITTEE FOR
THE WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE-
COMMITTEE HEARING. TODAY IS THE
TWENTY SIXTH OF MARCH. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK. WE'RE GONNA
GET STARTED AS A SUB COMMITTEE
WE'VE GOT SEVERAL THINGS TO GO
OVER BEFORE WE ACTUALLY GET
INTO THE SUBSTANCE OF THAT
AGENDA AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH A
WEEKEND CALLING THE MEETING TO
ORDER I'LL BEGIN BY SHARING A
FEW NOTES ABOUT THE LOGISTICS
OF OUR HEARING TODAY. THE STEPS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO HELP
PRESERVE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE AND ENSURE THE PUBLIC
TAXES. TO THIS DISCUSSION. THE
TO THE ONGOING PANDEMIC WE ARE
LIMITING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN BE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN THE HERE.
TO ENSURE MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA
AND THE PUBLIC HAVE ACCESS TO
OUR PROCEEDINGS TODAY. WE'RE
INSURING THERE ARE MULTIPLE
WAYS TO SERVE AND PARTICIPATE.
IN HIS HEARING TESTIMONY CAN BE
PROVIDED IN PERSON. VIA THE
PHONE OR VIA CONFERENCE AT TO
REMOTE LOCATIONS INSIDE THE
CAPITOL. AND ONE ON THE GROUNDS.
EVERYONE IN THE CAPITAL MUST
WEAR A MASK THIS INCLUDES HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM. AT THE
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM
AND THE CAPITOL GROUNDS REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. WE DO NOT
HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE
FOR YOU. LIKEWISE EVERYONE IN
HERE ROOM OR THE REMOTE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATIONS IS REQUIRED
TO PARTICIPATE. THE SOCIAL
PRACTICE SOCIAL DISTANCING
GIVEN THAT A NUMBER OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OF THE BILLS. ON THE
AGENDA WILL BE JOINING US
REMOTELY WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
BEAR WITH US IF WE NEED TO WORK
THROUGH ANY TECHNICAL ISSUES.
FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
PRESENT IN THE HEARING ROOM
WE'RE REQUIRING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PLEASE FOLLOW THE
DIRECTIONS. OF OUR SERGEANTS
AND POSTED GUIDANCE IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL. I WILL ASK THAT YOU
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ALSO
ASK THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM. ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING ONE LEAVING
THE CAPITAL. INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. THIS FOR THE WAY. IN
THE VIDEO CALL ROOM AND TO BE
ABLE TO TELL. FROM INSIDE
HEARING ROOM. WE MAY HAVE SOME
BILLS BILL WITNESSES. USE OF
THE WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOM. THIS CONFERENCE ROOM IS.
LOCATED IN ROOM ONE TWENTY
SEVENTH THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN IN THE
ROOM SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH THE
TESTIMONY. LIVE AND ASK
QUESTIONS OF THESE WITNESSES.
WE WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANYONE CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
PEN IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
FOUR. TWO ZERO TWO I REPEAT THE
NUMBER IT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO.
ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
WATERPARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV SCREEN. PLEASE CALL
WHEN THE AUTHOR THE BILL YOU
PLAN TO TESTIFY. ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS. ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE VEIL. FOLLOWING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCAST ANGER SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND ISSUES.
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF
YOU ARE A MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY OR FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL YOU WILL
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE AND WILL
NEED TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATOR PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE. AT.
916-319-2096 YEAH COMMITTEE
STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO
HELP. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. REACH BILL
WE ARE ALLOWING UP TO TWO MAIN
WITNESSES SUPPORT AND TO ME
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THESE
TWO WITNESSES HAVE BEEN MADE
KNOWN TO THE COMMITTEE IN
ADVANCE. OF THE HEARING EACH
WITNESS WILL HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES TO SPEAK. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ONLY. ANY
ADDITIONAL DETAIL YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE ABOUT YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL SHOULD BE
SUBMITTED IN WRITING. TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WILL FACE. REMEMBERS
IF YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND TO
ROLL CALL AS QUESTION A PROVIDE
COMMENT PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND.
AND TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE
WHEN IT IS YOUR TURN TO SPEAK.
YOUR PRESENT A BILL TO THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE PRESENT. FROM
THE MICHAEL AT THE WITNESS
TABLE. WE HAVE AN AGENDA UPDATE
A. B. FIVE THIRTY FOUR. A. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT HAVE BEEN
PULLED. AND CONSENT CALENDAR-
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF OTHER
ITEMS- THERE WE WILL GO OVER.
WOULD WE ACTUALLY STATUS QUORUM
AND- TAKEN ACTION ON THAT. SO
WE HAVE ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
SIX NOT QUITE THERE. NOT QUITE
THERE BUT- WE DO HAVE SOME BILL
AUTHORS. AND AT THE TOP OF THE
LIST. I GUESS THE GERMANS READY
TO GO- SO. PLEASE PRESENT.
MISTER. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER. AND MEMBER I WANT TO.
THE STAFF OF THE THREE FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFF. ON THIS
AND PIECE LEGISLATION. THIS
BILL SEVEN FIFTY FOUR. JUST
SIMPLY IS. THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES THE ABILITY. TO
GRANT AN EXTENSION. FOR OUR
GSA'S IS WE'RE GOING THROUGH
THE SIGNUP PROCESS IS WE'RE
GOING THROUGH THESE THINGS WITH
COLERIDGE WEEK SPECIALLY
MEMBERS WHAT. WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IS THAT. THIS PANDEMIC IS MADE
IT HARD FOR EVERYBODY ACROSS
THE BOARD TO REACH OUT AND GET
A HOLD OF PEOPLE. WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE IS GIVING THE
DEPARTMENT THE ABILITY. IF THEY
SO CHOOSE SO. TO EXTEND SOME
TIME SO PEOPLE CAN GET THEIR
DUCKS IN A ROW. NOW THIS ISN'T
ANYTHING NEW FOR OUR BODY THIS
YEAR ALONE. WE WORK ON AB EIGHT
FOUR EIGHTY TWO WARD HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CREATING AN EXTENSION AB SIX
FIFTY AL MURATSUCHI. EMPLOYER
PROVIDED BENEFIT HEALTHCARE
WORKERS FOR COVERT HAS A
PREMIUM PAY EXTENSIONS. AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE SERVE ORTEZ
EXTENDING CAL GRANT PROGRAM FOR
STUDENTS AB FIVE EIGHTY THREE
CHIU. EXTENDING MARRIAGE
LICENSE INSURANCE. AB ELEVEN
THIRTEEN MEDINA PAUL OF THE
CROSS SECONDARY TUITION AB
THIRTY TWO OCULAR CURRY ON
TELEHEALTH. I HEARD A FIRST AND
A SECOND ALL STOP READING OFF
THE SEVERAL BILLS THAT WE'VE
ALREADY DONE I DO UNDERSTAND
RESEARCHER YOU NEED TO
ESTABLISH FORMS LIKE AT THIS
POINT WE'LL HAVE ALL FOR IT YET
WE DO HAVE EIGHT MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND ASK FOR.
A ROLL CALL. AT GARCIA PRESENT.
DAHLE BUT BENNETT HERE BIGELOW
FRIEDMAN CRISTINA GARCIA KALRA
LEVINE- MURATSUCHI WHEN RUBIO
SALAS SMITH. VWS WARD. THANK
YOU WE ARE ON ITEM SEVENTY B.
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR THERE IS A
MOTION ANDA SECOND AND I DO
BELIEVE YOU HAVE SOME
WITNESSES- SUPPORTED THE BILL.
ABSOLUTELY MISTER PASTA
MODERATOR TO PLEASE- BEING THE
MENTOR WHAT IF COLLOMBIN.
WUNDERMAN THANK YOU THEIR LINES
ARE OPEN. HELLO CIRCUS HERE CAN
YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU CARE
GARCIA MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF OUR COUNTY AIMS MY
NAME'S TO PARTS NAGY BONTA
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS ARE COUNTY TO WORK HARD
AND INTERNISTS TO CARRY OUT THE
REQUIREMENTS SIGMA POLLUTING
OVER THIS LAST YEAR PANDEMIC
RESTRICTION HOWEVER DESPITE
THEIR BEST EFFORTS AND EPIC
RESTRICTIONS ARE PROVIDED ARE
COUNTIES CONDUCTING A KIND OF
FULL. STATE ENGAGE DATA SUBMIT
COMPLETE GROUNDWATER SUSTAINED
PLAN. TO D. W. Y. BY THE
DEADLINE OF JANUARY THIRTY OF
NEXT YEAR. BUT TO WORK HAVE
BEEN MARRIED BUT ARE ROOTED IN
STORE LACKING BROADBAND.
INFRASTRUCTURE GREAT WHICH ARE
BY APPLE. TO CONDUCT PUBLIC OUR-
IF THESE FROM SEVERAL OF OUR
MEMBER COUNTIES BROCADE
MINISTRY START LATE LAST YEAR
ASKING FOR ASSISTANCE AND ALL.
RELIEF FROM THE DEADLINE. IS
COUNTY MODOC CLASS. COLUSA IN
THE- AND OTHER COUNTIES A THING
ON HUMP. PERSON BEFORE.
INSECTICIDE ANY EXTENSION CHIU
RECOGNIZES OUR COUNTIES TO TAKE
OPERATES BY PROVIDING A SAFETY
VALVE FOR ONLY THE MOST EXIGENT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THREE NARAL
BY FORWARDING AN EXTENSION OF
NO MORE THAN A HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS. FOR COUNTIES TO COMPLETE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT AND
SUBMIT BETTER DROPPED TO GST IS
I'D LIKE TO TURN TO OUR SECOND
WITNESS AND THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS GERRY BYRNE THE PROVIDER
MODOC COUNTY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY I AM
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE AN AVENUE FOR AN
EXTENSION ON SIGMA DEADLINE I'M
NOT ONLY TESTIFYING FOR LACK OF
THE MODOC COUNTY WHICH SERVES
THE GFA FOR A BIG RALLY WATER
GROUNDWATER BASIN. FOR MANY
OTHER COUNTIES INCLUDING AS DID
MENTION COLUSA BUTTE FIFTY JUST
TO NAME A FEW WHICH ARE
EXPERIENCING THE SAME
CHALLENGES WE ARE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING HARD TO PREPARE THE
REQUIRED YET HE'S PROBABLY ARE
HAMPERED BY OUR ABILITY TO
RECEIVE MEANINGFUL PUBLIC INPUT
AS REQUIRED BY THE LAW GIVEN
CODE RESTRICTION AND VERY. POOR
INTERNET AND EVEN SELF SERVICE.
IN BOTH MODOC IN LAST SHARED.
AS WELL FROM AND SHARE BASIS.
PREPARATION OF THE DSPS EVENT.
BY COVERED. PREVENTING IN
PERSON MEETINGS AS WELL AS VERY
PORTANTINO. INTERNET SERVICE.
WITH ONLY 5% OF MODOC COUNTY
HAVING ACCESS TO BROADBAND.
IT'S MAKE THE ONLINE MEETING
OPTIONS NEAR IMPOSSIBLE. WE CAN
PROVIDE YOU WITH MANY EXAMPLES
OF PUBLIC MEMBERS TRYING TO
TAKE PART ONLINE WHO RUN UNABLE
TO DO SO. EVEN DID OF THE
ARCHITECTS OF THAT THAT THEY
TRY TO PARTICIPATE ONLINE IN
OUR MEETING. IN ADDITION THE
LAST TWO LIKE THE BATES AND
MEETING AT THE TOP COMPLETELY
BECAUSE NONEXISTENT SERVICE. WE
ARE WORKING HARD TO MEET THE-
BUT WE ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE
THE BEST PRODUCT WITHOUT BETTER
PUBLIC INPUT. NO NOTHING TO
STOP THE PROCESS OR TO DELAY IT
AND REASONABLY. BUT TO GIVE US
TIME GIVEN CALL WITH
RESTRICTIONS WHICH NO ONE COULD
HAVE FORESEEN. TO PREPARE THE
BEST PRODUCT POSSIBLE WITH
MEANINGFUL PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
AS REQUIRED BY THE LAW. WE USED
TO SEE THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION PLACE AND TO
PROVIDE MORE TIME TO SUBMIT THE
REQUIRED GST. IN FACT WE HAVE
SENT A LETTER THE LEGISLATURE
REQUESTING ADDITIONAL TIME
ALONG WITH MULTIPLE LETTERS TO
THE GOVERNOR. REQUESTING AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER ALLOWING MORE
TIME IN LIMITED CIRCUMSTANCES
SUCH AS OURS. IF ADOPTED THIS
LEGISLATION WILL NOT COMPLETE
SOLUTION WOULD PROVIDE A SAFETY
NET FOR A COUNTY. IF WHEN WE GO
TO ADOPT THE PLANS WE HAVE OUR
BOARDROOM FULL A DISGRUNTLED
RESIDENTS WHO RIGHTFULLY SAY.
THEY WERE NOT PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEVEN LAW. TO
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL PUBLIC INPUT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
OUR CONCERNS INTO
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AT THIS TIME WILL ASK OF-
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM THAT WANTED TO-
SUPPORT THIS BILL. SEE NO ONE
ON THE- DISPLAY THERE WILL OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINES FOR THOSE
WISHING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
WILL BE WHAT WE ASK OF YOU SO-
MODERATOR. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN FIVE FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
AM- WILL SCHEDULE WITNESSES WHO
TESTIFIED IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
IS THAT. WHAT I SHOULD DO. IF
YOU'RE IN FAVOR YES YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR- YES
POSITION. SIX ONE NINE ZERO
NINE STATE THAT. I CURRENTLY
HAVE MY COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. OKAY SO WE'LL GO
TO. THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO
END OF IT. WELL I'M TESTIFYING
IN FAVOR MY NAME IS MICHAEL
BRODSKY. WE HAD TWO PEOPLE
TESTIFIED ALREADY AND SO AT
THIS MOMENT OKAY I WANT. IF I
MADE FOR MY FINISH AT THIS
POINT WE'RE TAKING THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL SO
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
GUEST POSITION AND THAT THAT'S
ALL. MY NAME IS MICHAEL
BRODSKY- I'M AN ATTORNEY AT THE
U. S. POSITION ON EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY THIS. WILL IF THERE AREN'T
ANY OTHER CALLERS TO SUPPORT
THE MEASURE WILL GO ON TO WE
HAVE TO INDIVIDUALS REGISTERED
TO. SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL- SOLD MODERATOR. SOMETIMES
ARE OPEN THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M ROGER DICKINSON
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION LTC
SUPPORTS LOCAL POLICYMAKERS ON
ISSUES SUCH AS CLIMATE CHANGE
WATER ENERGY AND COMMUNITY
DESIGN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK LTC
OPPOSES AB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR.
ONE SIX MY WITHIN ACTED AT
LEAST TWO THINGS WERE
MANIFESTLY CLEAR FIRST IT WAS
APPARENT THE GROUNDWATER
THROUGHOUT THE STATE HAVE BEEN
SUBJECT TO SERIOUS THE DEMONS
OF BEER OVER DRAFTING FOR
DECADES THE CONSEQUENCES WERE
VERGING ON CATASTROPHIC AND
GROWING WORSE EXPONENTIALLY DUE
pEQUALLY APPARENT THAT
NOTWITHSTANDING THE URGENCY OF
THE SITUATION TIME WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO DEVELOP ADOPT AND
IMPLEMENT A CORRECTIVE APPROACH
THAT SIGNAL WAS WRITTEN TO GIVE
COMMUNITIES FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS.
TO ORGANIZE AND PREPARE A PLAN.
BASINS WITH CRITICAL OVER
DRAFTING WERE A LOT OF FIVE
YEARS TO SUBMIT THEIR PLANS TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES AND THEY HAVE DONE SO.
THE BASINS WITH LESS SECURED
OVERDRAFT IN DRAFTING WERE
GIVEN SEVEN YEARS SEVEN YEARS
TO SUBMIT THEIR PLANS. EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR WOULD OPERATE
DECISIONAL TIME TO
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE ALREADY
HAD MORE THAN SIXTY YEARS TO
ACT. AND WHICH WILL HAVE THE
FULL SEVEN YEARS TO DO SO BY
NEXT JANUARY. WELL THERE'S NO
DISPUTE THAT THE PANDEMIC HAS
MADE VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING MORE
DIFFICULT IN THE LAST YEAR. THE
PANDEMIC CANNOT BE AN EXCUSE IN
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE SO
MUCH TIME WITH ROVIDED TO MEET
SEGMENTS REQUIREMENTS. THE
URGENCY OF ADDRESSING ARE OVER
DRAFTING OF GROUNDWATER HAS NOT
DIMINISHED BUT HAS ONLY GROWN
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF STIGMA.
INDEED WITH THE SNOW PACK 40%
BELOW AVERAGE THIS YEAR
FOLLOWING A NOTHER FAR BELOW
AVERAGE SEASON LAST YEAR. AND
THE PROSPECT OF ANOTHER DROUGHT
LOOMING WE CAN ILL AFFORD ANY
DELAY IN TAKING THE STEPS
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR NO VOTE
ON AB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE'VE GOT
ANOTHER PERSON HERE SIGNED UP
ROGER DICKINSON. HOWEVER THAT
WHAT'S ROGER- THIS IS ROMANTIC
OUR MACHO ELLIOT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDWATER COALITION. I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE THIRD. THE
BRACE AND- THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AGAIN ROMANTIC
HARBOTTLE ELLIOT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDWATER COALITION I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SEVEN
FIFTY FOUR THE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDWATER COALITION IS AN
ORGANIZATION OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
ENTITIES LOCATED THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND CONSISTS OF
EXPERTS WITH TECHNICAL LEGAL
AND PROFESSIONAL GROUNDWATER
AND RELATED EXPERTISE. CDC
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN SUSTAINABLY
MANAGING GROUNDWATER LONG
BEFORE THE PASSAGE OF SIGMA
WHICH WE SUPPORTED IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN UNFORTUNATELY CDC
METRIC RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT BY PUSHING BACK
THE DEADLINE FOR MANAGEMENT
UNDER GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN WILL RESULT
IN INCREASED CAUGHT. DID YOU
SEE REPRESENTS WATER AGENCIES
THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING TO FORM
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCIES AS REQUIRED BY STATE
LAW I KNOW FIRST HAND THAT
PUSHED BACK THE DEADLINE FOR A
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY PLAN
WILL ONLY LEAD TO INCREASED
COSTS. ADDITIONALLY UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE STATE WATER
BOARD HAS THE OPTION TO GIVE A
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
DAYS TO REMEDY AN INCOMPLETE OR
ON A DOCTOR GRAHAM UNDERSTAND
ABILITY PLAN SO THERE'S NO NEED
FOR THE HUNDRED AND. EIGHTY DAY
EXTENSION AND THIS GIRL. I'VE
FORMER SENATOR DICK AND ALL
THEIR ONE OF THE OF THE SIGNAL
THEY- JUST MENTION. THE JANUARY
THIRTY TWENTY TWENTY TWO
DEADLINE FOR HIGHER MEDIUM
PRIORITY BASIN. TO BE MANAGED
UNDER A GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN HAS BEEN IN
PLACE SINCE JANUARY OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN. AND ALL GROWN OR
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES HAVE
BEEN WORKING TOWARDS THE
EXISTING DEADLINE FOR THE LAST
SIX YEARS. AND WE'RE STARING
DOWN ANOTHER DROUGHT WHEN WE
KNOW THE GROUND WATER IS GOING
TO BE TAPPED TO MAKE UP FOR THE
LACK OF SURFACE WATER NOW'S NOT
THE TIME TO POSTPONE OR DELAY
THIS NECESSARY WORK. THERE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA GROUNDWATER
COALITION MUST RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NO
VOTE ON EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL. ASK NOW IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN THE- TELECONFERENCE ROOM
THAT'S GOING TO BE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION. ANYONE HERE PRESENT
WE SHOULD TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY WILL OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR FOR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL A. B.
SOME FIFTY FOUR. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN
FIVE FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
DO HAVE TO IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE
ONE MOMENT FOR THE FIRST LINE
THANK YOU. THE LION ONE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THERE IS ONLY ONE- WITH LET ME
WATER SENATE- I THINK SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY AND WE'RE
CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR MATHIS AND IT
BECAUSE THE POINTS MADE BY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION
THANK YOU AND WE ARE JUST. NOW
THANK YOU. EXTRUDER NAME YOUR
RIGHT ONE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
HIS NAME OR HIS AGE AND
POSITION PLEASE. BUT I DON'T
WANT FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN RODRIGUEZ
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
IN OPPOSITION ALSO CALLING IN
OPPOSITION FOR LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND FEAR BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER CALLS
THANK YOU. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'LL BRING YOU
BACK TO THE BODY THERE WAS A
MOTION THE SECOND IT WAS MADE-
PRIOR TO HAVING A ESTABLISH
QUORUM WITH THE STATUS OF.
CORNELL IS THAT DOUBLES- MAKERS
OF THE MOTION WANT TO PUT THAT
BACK ON THE TABLE. OKAY SO THIS
RUBIO MADE THE FIRST MOTION.
AND A SECOND WAS MY PUNISHMENT
LOW. OKAY ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF THE AUTHOR ON THE
MEASURE. I'VE NO NO NO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH QUITE. OR MAYBE
ANYONE I CAN ANSWER C. FIVE.
WALMART HOW TO GET THE JOB DONE
AND DONE RIGHT THIS WHOLE.
COMMENT A LITTLE DIFFERENT NEED
TO NEARLY TWO HONDA RESOLUTION
WITH THIS- WITH A SINGLE. OR
PASSED YEAH DEFINITELY DO IT
FIVE ONE OF THE- ON OF THAT-
WORK. WITH. I WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND EVERYONE OUR GREAT FORM
ON SEPTEMBER. EIGHT FIFTY.
SEVEN ONE YEARS AGO. YEAH
MATTER SEVENTY ONE YEAR ONE
WHAT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS. THIS
MAY. A LOT OF. ASKED ASKING FOR
A LITTLE TIME. PLEASE TAKE A
ONE A LITTLE WORK. AS THE
AUTHORS ASK I THINK IT'S READ
AND RESPECT. I KNOW IT'S HARD
FOR THE OFF IT'S HARD FOR SOME.
BUT I RECOGNIZING THE HUNTER
AND SEVENTY YEARS THAT HAVE
PASSED. HAS BROUGHT US TO A
PLACE WHERE WE NEED TO START
FOCUSING ON. THE ISSUES OF
WATER. SO I WOULD- COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS ACTIONS AND
EFFORTS TO TRY TO HELP SOME OF
THOSE WHO ARE STILL LINGERING
AND STRUGGLING WITH TRYING TO
FIND THE ANSWERS THAT ARE
NEEDED. TO HAVE SUSTAINABILITY.
THANK YOU MISTER RIGO. WHICH
MEANT. THANK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS OF THE AUTHOR- THINK
THAT THERE'S REQUEST OF GONE
OUT TO ELIMINATION IS TRYING TO
COME UP WITH A SOLUTION BUT I
JUST LIKE TO GIVE THE MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE. MY
BACKGROUND IN TERMS OF I SERVED
ON A GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY FOR. MORE THAN FIVE
YEARS- AND DURING THE WHOLE
TIME THAT WE WERE TRYING TO
BRING- THE OUR BASE IN THAT
COME UP WITH A PLAN FOR BASIN
IN TERMS OF SUSTAINABILITY. BUT
THAT'S IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT AGENCY- THAT I SERVED
ON IT WAS AN AGENCY ACTUALLY
FORMED. MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO TO STOP THE SALT
WATER INTRUSION BECAUSE THE
OCEAN DEAD PROMPTED BASIN DOWN
BELOW SEA LEVEL. AND NOW THEY
WERE GETTING SALT WATER
INTRUSION. AND THEY WERE GIVEN
A MANDATE BY THIS VERY BODY IS
LEGISLATURE OF CALIFORNIA. TO
GET THAT ALL IN SHAPE- BY AND
THE DEADLINE WAS TWENTY TEN
THAT THEY HAD THE THEY HAD THIS
BRING THIS. SALT WATER
INTRUSION- I TO. RIVERSIDE AND
SAVE THIS PRECIOUS SOCCER FOR A
TREMENDOUS AQUIFER THAT THEY
HAVE THERE. AND I JUST WANT TO
TELL YOU THE HISTORY OF IT WAS
NOTHING BUT- KICKING THE CAN
DOWN THE ROAD FIGHTING EVERY
DEADLINE ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
AND THEY- CONSIST- DID NOT MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS AND I JUST
WANT TO TELL YOU THAT'S WHEN
YOU START THIS EXTENSION OF
DEADLINES. THERE'S ALWAYS
ANOTHER REASON AND THERE WAS
ALWAYS ANOTHER REASON WE DIDN'T
HAVE ENOUGH DATA THE EXPERT WAS
TIED UP DESERVES IT IN IT. AND
TO KICK SOMETHING DOWN MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS- WAS WAS LIKE
I JUST LIKE VERY- IT'S VERY
DETRIMENTAL TO THE PEOPLE OF
THE TURRET COUNTY SO AFTER
SERVING FIVE YEARS IN HEARING
EVERY REASON UNDER THE SUN- AT
THAT- YEAH IT'S SERVING IN THAT
CAPACITY. I AM VERY RELUCTANT
TO HAVE US BEGIN DOWN THIS
PROCESS- HERE SO- CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF THE
AUTHOR- BUT I THINK IT IS
DANGEROUS FOR US TO DO THIS. WE
ALREADY HAVE THEY'VE HAD SEVEN
YEARS. SEVEN YEARS KNOWING
THERE WAS A DEADLINE WHEN
CULVER HT PEOPLE COULD SAY HEY
WORK WHATEVER WAS YOU'RE
PLANNING ON DOING YOU GOT IF
YOU HAVE TO GET IT DONE. BUT
INSTEAD OF ALWAYS THE DEFAULT
WHEN IT COMES TO GROUND WATER
SEEMS TO BE JUST PUSH THE
DEADLINE. WE'RE GOING INTO THE
SECOND YEAR THAT'S OF THIS
DROUGHT THE GROUNDWATER BASINS
HAVE NOT RECOVERED FROM THE
FIRST TRIAL- IF WE DON'T. A
SENSE OF URGENCY AND HOLD
PEOPLE TO THAT SENSE OF URGENCY
I THINK WE JUST WON'T GET THE
JOB DONE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE COUNTING. ON US
TO TRY TO GET GROUND LIBATIONS
FOR THE FIRST TIME TO BE
PUMPING AT A SUSTAINABLE LEVEL
I CERTAINLY RESPECT THE
DIFFERENCES THAT WE MIGHT HAVE
ON THIS. AND CERTAINLY RESPECT
THAT PEOPLE WANT TO TRY TO HELP
IN IN THAT THE- PEOPLE THAT ARE
OUT THERE TRYING TO DO THIS BUT
I. A LOOK I LIKE TO ALERT US TO
THE DANGERS OF STARTING DOWN
THE ROAD OF EXTENDING DEADLINES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER BENNETT. THIS IS A
COMMENT YES PLEASE SLOWING.
YEAH I APPRECIATE YOU KNOW
ASKING THESE QUESTIONS AND THEN
THE AUTHOR. TRYING TO GIVE A
VOICE TO PEOPLE- THAT QUITE
FRANKLY YOU SEEM TO HAVE BEEN
IN DENIAL- OVER THE PAST HALF
DECADE- ARE YOU REALLY A CLEAN
YOU KNOW MY COLLEAGUES SOME
OFFENDED ON THIS AND WE ARE
STARING AT. A POINT OF NO
RETURN WHEN IT COMES TO WATER%
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
EXTREME DROUGHT THE CLIMATE.
CRISIS IS- ON TOP OF US AND WE
SEEM TO BE THINKING LET'S JUST
CONTINUE TO GIVE PEOPLE MORE
TIME. WHEN THEY'VE HAD A LOT OF
TIME AND- YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE-
WE SEE EXACTLY WHAT IS
HAPPENING- IT WOULD BE LIKE WE
WOULD BE IN DENIAL- THAT WERE
IN THE MIDST OF THIS DROUGHT-
IF WE WERE TO. THINK THAT WE
CAN GET PEOPLE- ANY MORE TIME
THAN THEY HAVE RIGHT NOW SO I
UNFORTUNATELY HAVETO VOTE NO
BUT AGAIN I YOU KNOW IT'S FAIR
ENOUGH FOR THE AUTHORED AT TO
RAISE THESE QUESTIONS AND TRY
TO HELP OTHER COMMUNITIES-
BUSTLE TO EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
OUR MISSILES. THANK RICH
CHAIRMAN MISTER MATHIS SEVEN
QUICK SIMPLE QUESTION- THE
EXTENSION THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR IN THIS IS IT BECAUSE- THE
FOLKS JUST DON'T WANT TO
EMBRACE SIGNAL OR IS IT BECAUSE
OF OTHER THINGS IS BECAUSE A
KOBE IT IS BECAUSE THEY JUST
CAN'T GET TOGETHER- WHAT'S THE
REASON FOR THE EXTENSION THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION MISTER
SALAS. THE EXTENSION HERE THAT
THIS ISN'T ONE IT'S NOT A
MANDATORY EXTENSION SO I'D LIKE
TO CLEAR THE AIR ON THAT THIS
IS NOT KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD. THIS IS NOT DENYING THE
FACT THAT SIGMA NEEDS TO GET
DONE AND THAT IT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN QUICKLY. I REPRESENT AT
MY HOMETOWN IN FACT IS THE CITY
WITHOUT WATER PORTABLE
CALIFORNIA. WHO GOT. AFFECTED
THE MOST OUT OF THE LAST
DROUGHT. WE WENT THROUGH. WHO
STILL HAS PEOPLE LIVING IN
THIRD WORLD WATER CONDITIONS.
SO I KNOW THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE WITH GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY. MY COMMUNITY
FACES THESE DAYS. THE FACT IS
THAT WHEN ALL THIS WAS SAID IN
PLAN. SO IT WAS NOT IN THE
CARDS. A GLOBAL PANDEMIC WAS
NOT IN THE CARDS. THIS BILL
ISN'T TO HELP THE BAD ACTORS
THIS BILL GIVES THE DEPARTMENT
V. OPTION MEMBERS THE OPTION
THEY DON'T HAVE TO IT GIVES
THEM A SIMPLE OPTION TO SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT MR SALAS YOUR GROUP
YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN GOOD ACTORS
YOU GUYS BEEN WORKING YOU'VE
BEEN COMMUNICATING WITH US WE
WANT TO HELP YOU OUT TO MAKE
SURE EVERY I IS DOTTED EVERY T.
IS CROSSED. IN THIS IS DONE
CORRECTLY. YOU KNOW WHAT.
MISTER BENNETT YOU'RE JUST SO
YOU GUYS ARE A MESS WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GIVE YOU THE
EXTENSION. SO THEY DON'T HAVE
TO THAT'S ALL THE SIMPLY DOES
IS GIVE THEM THE OPTION TO DO
SO IF THEY SO CHOOSE SO. THAT'S
IT MISTER SALAS THANK YOU FOR
THE COST THANK YOU MISTER
MATHIS. ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY
THANK YOU PLEASE I SPENT SAY
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IN MY REGION WHICH-
THIS BILL DOESN'T COVER BUT IF
THE SUPPORT IS COMING FROM MY
COUNTIES. WHO ARE VERY SMALL
AND HAVE BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY THROUGH THIS PROCESS
IF YOU KNOW YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT- THE COUNTIES WAS. YOU
KNOW SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT
IS VERY HRD FOR COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS TO COME UP WITH
THOSE ANSWERS. SO WE CAN'T
COMPARE MODOC TO LA IT'S NOT
THE SAME COMPARISON AT ALL SO I
THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRING
THIS FORWARD BECAUSE IT WILL
GIVE THEM THE OPTION TO SHOW
YOU. FOR THE AGENCIES HOW HARD
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING TO COME UP
WITH A SOLUTION TO. TO HIT
THESE REGULATIONS THAT ARE NOW
BEEN MANDATED ON THEM SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH I'LL BE SUPPORTING
IT TODAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AT
ABSOLUTELY MISTER CHAIRMAN
JUST. AGAIN IN SHORT MEMBERS WE
WE'VE HAD. MULTIPLE OTHER
PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE EXTENSIONS
AYE I KNOW SOME OF YOU WERE
HERE WHEN I GOT STARTED WHEN
OVER THE LAST- ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN THIRTEEN BY MR MEDINA.
THIS EXTENDS POST SECONDARY-
FEE WAIVERS. AB THIRTY TWO.
OCULAR CURRY. GIVES THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TIME TO EXTEND FOR
TELEHEALTH. AB. FIVE SIXTY TWO
MR LOW ON MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ANOTHER EXTENSION AB
FOUR EIGHTY TWO MR WARD ON
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT SB SIX FIFTY.
MEMBER MURATSUCHI EMPLOYER
PROVIDED BENEFITS HEALTH CARE
WORKERS FOR HAZARD PAY FOR CALL
IT EXTENSION AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE CERVANTES. CAL GRANT
PROGRAM EXTENSION AB FIVE
EIGHTY THREE CHELL. IN
EXTENSION MEMBERS I CAN GO ON
AND ON AND ON WITH THE
EXTENSIONS THAT OUR BODY HAS
GIVEN DUE TO CULVERT SO DON'T
THINK THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
NEW THAT THIS IS A HAND OUT FOR
BAD ACTING GSA'S MEMBERS THIS
IS NOT THIS IS VERY AGAIN VERY
SPECIFICALLY WRITTEN. SO THE
DEPARTMENT. CAN HELP THOSE WHO
ARE TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING TO HELP THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN. DAMAGE DUE TO CULTIVATE
BECAUSE THEY NEED A LOT OF
THESE PLANS LIKE- ASSEMBLY
WOMAN DOLLY MENTION OUR ROLE
COMMUNITIES THEY DON'T HAVE THE
INTERNET. A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE
THE ONLY WAY TO GET THE
COMMUNITIES TOGETHER IS IN
PERSON WHICH HASN'T BEEN
ALLOWED. SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
WE WANT WE'RE CONCERNED FROM
THE OPPOSITION ABOUT COST.
IMAGINE THE COST OVER THE
LAWSUIT FROM THE COMMUNITIES
THAT DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO
HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD.
MEMBERS ASK YOU OPEN YOUR
HEARTS. GIVE THESE PEOPLE A
CHANCE GIVE THE DEPARTMENT THE
ABILITY TO CHOOSE. IN WITH THIS
OUT SO WE CAN GET SIGMA DONT
AND MOVE FORWARD AS THE STATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE WE
HAVE A NON RECCO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL THANK YOU
DAVID AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES DOES HAVE. THE
FINAL DISCRETION IT IS IT'S ONE
THING- THAT WE WANT TO CONTINUE
TO SEE COME BEFORE US IT ISN'T
A GOOD PRECEDENT THAT SETS
ACTUALLY. A FACT THAT GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THE TINY
PROBABLY. COULDN'T BE A WORSE
FOR YOU TO PRESENT THIS BILL
GIVEN THE DECLARATION OF THE
TRIAL BUT NEVER THE LESS. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU ARE
ADVOCATING FOR YOUR COMMUNITIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF OTHER
MEMBERS UP HERE AND SO WE WANT
TO BE. SUPPORTIVE IN THAT
ASPECT SO THERE IS A MOTION
THERE IS A SECOND. AND DOLLARS
FOR ROLL CALL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA HI DOLLY.
DOLLY HI. SENATE BILL BENNETT
NO BIGELOW YES BIGELOW HI
FRIEDMAN. CRISTINA GARCIA
KALRA. LEVINE NO LEVINE NOW.
MURATSUCHI NO ONE. RUBIO RUBIO
AYE SALAS SALAS I SMITH. SMITH
I VIP DO IT VIA PADILLA I WARD.
WE'LL LEAVE THE CALL OPEN FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO TAKE A
POSITION ON THIS BEFORE WE COME
UP WELL THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CENTER WHICH WILL BE
MISTER FRAZIER I'M GONNA JUST
READ OFF AGAIN THAT- A. B. FOUR
THIRTY FOUR AND- FIVE THIRTY
FOUR LONG WITH FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT HAVE BEEN PULLED. FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. HAVE BEEN
PULLED AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR
HAS A COUPLE OF ITEMS A B. FOUR
FOUR TWO A. B. ELEVEN NINETY.
AB SEVENTY ONE A. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY NINE AND A B. TWELVE
NINETY EIGHT IF I CAN GET A
MOTION TO MOVE. TO COUNTER
RUBIO THE APPROVAL OF ON THE
SECOND. AND WILL CALLER
QUESTION ON BEACON TECHNOLOGY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND TO CONSENT
CALENDAR EDUARDO GARCIA HI
EDUARDO GARCIA I DOLLY. DALI
I'D BENNETT. BENNETT I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I FRIEDMAN. CRISTINA
GARCIA KALRA LEVIN LEVINE I'M
MURATSUCHI WHEN RUBIO RUBIO AYE
SALAS SALAS I SMITH. SMITH I'D
BE A PRODUCER BE ABLE TO DO IT
I WARD. THANK YOU WE DO NOW
HAVE A BE NINE SEVENTY NINE MR
FRAZIER- YOU DO HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. PLEASE A
PRESENT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERS. EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY NINE. SKEWS ME OR
REQUIRE ANY COVER PROJECT
WITHIN THE SACRAMENTO SAN
JOAQUIN DELTA TO COMPLETE AN
ANALYSIS OF THE IMPACTS OF SEA
LEVEL RISE. ON ANY PROJECT. FOR
TOO LONG DECISIONS IN THE
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN DELTA
HAVE BEEN GUIDED BY POLITICAL
CONSIDERATIONS RATHER BEEN.
RATHER THAN BY THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE. WHILE THE
STATE HAS MADE STRIDES TOWARD
RESOLVING THESE ISSUES OVER THE
PAST TWO YEARS CONFIDENCE IN
THE STATE DECISION MAKING HAS
BEEN DIMINISHED AMONG THE
RESIDENTS OF THE DELTA. AB
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE TAKES A
SMALL STEP TOWARDS RESTORING
THAT CONFIDENCE. IN THIS BILL
WILL CODIFY EXISTING OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL GUIDANCE. ON
SEA LEVEL RISE FOR THE LEGAL
DELTA. ENSURING THAT ANY FUTURE
PROJECT WILL HAVE TO IT. WILL
HAVE TO ANALYZE THE IMPACTS OF
AT LEAST A TEN FOOT RIGHTS.
GIVEN ARE RAPIDLY ADVANCING
SCIENTIFIC UNDERSTANDING OF SEA
LEVEL RISE IT'S TIME TO EMBRACE
COMMONSENSE PLANNING ANALYSIS
AND A DEPUTATION MEASURES SUCH
AS- THE ONES RECOMMENDED BY THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL.
AGENCIES ARE ALREADY
ENCOURAGING ENCOURAGE UTILIZES
GUIDANCE IN THEIR PLANNING
PERMITTING AND INVESTMENT
DECISIONS NAB'S NINE SEVEN NINE
ONE SURE THAT THE BENEFITS OF
THE GUIDANCE CAN BE ENJOYED BY
RESIDENTS OF THE DELTA. FOR THE
YEARS TO COME. LEGISLATURE HAS
COME HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
PROVIDING FOR THE INCLUSION OF
CONCRETE SEA LEVEL RISE
ANALYSIS AND STATUTES. AB NINE
SEVEN NINE SIMPLY UPDATES THE
STATUTE TO INCLUDE THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE ON SEA LEVEL
RISE PRODUCTION PROJECTIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I HAVE WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT. MICHAEL BROAD STREET
FROM SAVE THE CALIFORNIA DELTA
ALLIANCE THANK YOU. PLEASE
PROCEED. MY RECORD POLICE.
MODERATE CAN YOU LEFT OUT THE
KEY WITNESS. MR BRODSKY MR
BRODSKY PRESENT YES KEEP IN
MIND ARE OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU. YEAH
YES SORRY ABOUT THAT I WAS
HAVING A TECHNICAL PROBLEM- YES
MICHAEL BRODSKY OF REPRESENTING
STATE THE CALIFORNIA DELTA
ALLIANCE A SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY NINE. AND
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY BECAUSE
SEALEVEL RISE. AND ACCOUNTING
FOR SEA LEVEL RISE IN PROJECT
PLANNING IN THE DELTA IS VERY
IMPORTANT- MUCH OF THE DELTA OF
LIFE CONSIDERABLY BELOW SEA
LEVEL. AND RISING SEA LEVEL
WILL PUT INCREASING PRESSURE ON
OUR LEVEES AND THEREFORE
PREDICTING- ACCURATELY HOW
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IS
IMPORTANT FOR PROJECT PLANNING.
ALSO IN THE DELTA THE ECOLOGY
OF THE DELTA IS DEPENDENT ON A
VERY DELICATE FRESH AND SALT
WATER MIX. AND L. C. LEVEL
RISES THAT FRESH SALT WATER MIX
WILL CHANGE ADD SALT WATER
APPROACH WAS FURTHER INTO THE
DELTA. SO SEALABLE RICE IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT- WITH REGARD. TO
PLANNING DELTA PROJECTS. UNDER
EXISTING LAW THE BASIC STANDARD
IS FOR DELTA PROJECT PLANNING
THAT WE USE BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE BUT THAT DOESN'T
DETERMINE. WHAT PROTOCOLS AND
WHAT STANDARDS ARE TO BE USED-
WHEN PREDICTING SEA LEVEL RISE
SO THIS BILL BRING CERTAINTY.
BY SPECIFYING PARTICULAR
STANDARDS THAT ARE THE MOST
RECENT AND CONSIDERED- THE
PASSED AT THIS TIME. AND SO
THAT WILL ELIMINATE A LOT OF
THE FUTURE WILL BRING CERTAINTY
TO PROJECT PLANNING IT WILL PUT
AT BASICALLY THE TOP OF THE
CHECKLIST FOR PROJECT
PROPONENTS IN THE DELTA WHAT
THEY HAVE TO DO IN REGARDS TO
PLANNING FOR SEA LEVEL RISE. SO
THAT THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE WON'T
BE OVERLOOKED OR MISSED SO-
THAT'S WHY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU SIR. I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND BEEN REGISTERED SO WE'LL
ASK DOES ANYONE IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM. TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL. CASEY NO ONE
ANYONE HERE IN THE CHAMBER. NO
ONE SO WILL OPEN UP THE LINES
OF FOR THOSE WANTING TO SUPPORT
EIGHTY NINE SEVEN NINE. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT NINE SEVEN NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE TO IN Q. OVER
LINE ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE ONE FOUR FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LEVINE RIGHT ONE
FORTY EIGHTH PLEASE GO AHEAD- I
APOLOGIZE- I'M FOR ANY
OPPOSITION- THIS IS DENNIS ABI
ONLY BE UP OF. SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN SANTA
CLARITA WATER DISTRICT- WE ARE
OPPOSED. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER LICENSE YOU AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE WILL. BRING THE MATTER TO
THE DICE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR. COMMENTS OUR MOTION TO
MOVE AB NINE SEVEN NINE I HAVE
A SIMPLE COMMENT PLEASE WAIT A
MINUTE BEFORE WE VOTE THAT IS A
MENTION OF THE AUTHOR BEFORE
HAD SOME OF THE ISSUES OF COME
UP RIGHT AT THE END THAT I
HAVEN'T HAD TIME TO EXPLORE SO
I WILL NOT I WILL NOT BE.
OPPOSING THIS COMING OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE BUT I JUST WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW I LOOK FORWARD TO
COMMUNICATING WITH HIM BEFORE
IT FORGET TO THE FLOOR AND MAY
MAY HAVE A DIFFERENT PICTURE
DIFFERENT POSITION WHEN IT GETS
THERE AS MY RESEARCH COMES
FORWARD ABSOLUTE CERTAINLY
DOLLAR THANK YOU FLOW THIS BILL
MOVING OUT HERE SOME REVIEW YES
I THINK YOU MISTER FRAZIER. I
AS WELL- WILL SUPPORT THE
MEASURE BUT WITH IN HOPES THAT
WE CAN COME UP WITH AN
AGREEMENT I WE'VE GOT A LOT OF
LEAD OPPOSITION FROM MY
DISTRICT IN PARTICULAR AND SO
THAT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME
TO- NOT ACKNOWLEDGE THE- THAT
THERE'S ISSUES WITH THIS SO IF
YOU CAN PLEASE. KEEP US UPDATED
IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION I WANT TO
COME UP WITH A NUMBER OF DEGREE
MEANT- BEFORE IT COMES TO THE
FLOOR SO I WANNA YOU KNOW MAKE
SURE THAT THAT'S HEARD AND FOR
THE FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT THAT
ARE OPPOSING- IF I CAN HAVE A
COMMITMENT FROM YOU TO WORK
WITH THEM SO THAT WE CAN COME
UP WITH AN AGREEMENT THAT
SALUTE AND MIXTURE HAVE WE
HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION. SO
WE HAD ONE PERSON THAT WAS
GOING TO TESTIFY WE HAD ONE
PERSON COLIN I HAVE JENNIFER
PIERRE FOR THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS THAT WAS GOING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. AND- NOT
SURE IF. THEN THE I DON'T KNOW.
IF YOU'RE READY ME- YES PLEASE.
OKAY ARE OTHER AND GOOD EVENING
CHAIR OF THE CA MY NAME'S
JENNIFER PIERRE AND I'M THE
GENERAL MANAGER OF THE STATE
WATER CONTRACTORS REPRESENTING
TWENTY SEVEN OF THE TWENTY NINE
PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THAT CONTRACT WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES FOR STATE WATER
PROJECT WATER. WE SUPPORT THE
DOT THE PLAN INCLUDING ITS
IMPLEMENTATION OF STAKEHOLDER
ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION AND WATER
SUPPLY RELIABILITY. AB NINE
SEVEN NINE WOULD REQUIRE PUBLIC
AGENCIES BUSINESSES AND PRIVATE
PROPERTY OWNERS TO ANALYZE THE
IMPACT OF A WIDE ARRAY OF
MODELS SEALEVEL RISE
PROJECTIONS ON EVERY PROJECT IN
THE DOUBTS AND NO MATTER HOW
SMALL. IT IS AS COSTLY AS IT IS
UNNECESSARY AND WOULD BE
QUICKLY OUTDATED AS CLIMATE
CHANGE SCIENCE ABOUT. THE BILL
WOULD IMPOSE. BECAUSE ON F.
COUPLE AT EVERY PROJECT IN THE
DELTA TO COMPLETE THIS
EXTENSIVE ANALYSIS INCLUDING
THOSE PROJECT EXEMPTED BY C.
CLASS. IT MANDATE THE VALUATION
OF A HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
SEA LEVEL RISE SCENARIOS OVER
THIRTEEN TIME FRAME. INCLUDING
AN EXTREME SEA LEVEL RISE
SCENARIO FOR THE YEAR TWENTY
ONE FIFTY. THE BILL WOULD
IMPOSE CONSIDERABLE COSTS AN
UNDUE BURDEN ON THE PRODUCT
OPPONENTS INCLUDING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THE LANDOWNERS.
TO CONDUCT SUCH A COMPLEX THE
LEVEL RIGHT NOW SAYS WHICH
REQUIRES EXPERTS WITH SPECIFIC
NEEDS EXPERIENCE. AB NINE SEVEN
NINE ALSO UNNECESSARY THE DELTA
PLAN ALREADY REQUIRES THE
APPLICATION OF BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE THE PROJECT TO THE
DELTA THAT SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECT
THE STATE POLITICAL CALLS.
WHICH ALREADY INCLUDES AN
EVALUATION OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AFFECT INCLUDING SEA LEVEL
RISE. BASED ON THE INVOLVING
SCIENCE OF GLOBAL CLIMATE
CHANGE. IN ADDITION W. R. HAS
STUDIED AND CONTINUES TO STUDY
THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE ON
THE STATE WATER PROJECT. AND
THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL
ABOUT HALFWAY THROUGH WITH THE
DELTA DOUBTS PROCESS. WHICH
STUDIES THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ON THE DELTA AND WILL
OFFER DELTA SPECIFIC. GUIDANCE
FOR FUTURE PLANNING. THE
OUTLOOK OF A STATIC EIGHTEEN
APPROACH TO IS THE- OCEAN TO
SET. COUNCILS IN TWENTY. APPLY
IN A PIECEMEAL. THE EVERY
SINGLE ACTIVITY IN CURRENT
ADULT THAT WILL IMPEDE.
ACHIEVING THE STATE CODE WILL
CALL FOR THE DELTA APP
ECOSYSTEM RESTORATION RELIABLE
WATER SUPPLIES. BY IMPOSING
EXCESSIVE EXPENDITURES OF TIME
AND MONEY ON PIECEMEAL REPORT.
FOR THESE REASONS WE MUST
OPPOSE EIGHTY NINE SEVEN NINE
IN OUR JOURNAL VOTE ON THE
MEASURE. AT THE SAME THE
COMMITTEE SOMETIME THIS EVENING
I WAS HOPING I COULD JUST NO
OTHER WATER AGENCIES ON OUR
LETTER. AND INCLUDE ANALOG
VALUES KERN WATER AGENCY
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
KERN COUNTY WATER AGENCY
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THE HOBBIT
WATER AGENCY PALMDALE WATER
DISTRICT STANDARD YOU KNOW
GOLLY MISS THE WATER DISTRICT.
THANK A REAL VALUE IS A LOT OF
THE SIX SANTA CLARA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT SANTA CLARITA
VALLEY WATER AGENCIES ANGERED
AUDIO TAP WATER AGENCY. TULARE
LAKE BASIN WATER START DISTRICT
AND SEMI TRAFFIC WATER STORAGE
DISTRICT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I KNOW THAT- WE DID
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR. THOSE
WANTING TO REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSING. POSITION I'LL ASK
AGAIN THE MODERATOR SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE BEFORE WE
BRING. IT BACK TO- THE MEMBERS
HERE. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AB EIGHT NINE SEVEN
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I DO
HAVE ONE LINE IN Q. RIGHT ON
ONE FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CARE NUMBERS MONICA
MILAREPA THINK VALLEY WATER AT
THE LIGHT AND CLEAR VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT THE ACT
RESPECTIVELY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BALLOT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL. THERE
ISN'T ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
WILL BRING YOU BACK TO THE
DíAS. THERE ARE SOME MEMBER
QUESTIONS ABOUT ALREADY RAISED.
QUESTION SIR- THANK YOU MISTER
FRASER BRING IN THIS FARMS BUT
WITH ALL THE OPPOSITION YOU
HAVE A SAID A MOJAVE WATER
AGENCY FOR FOUR YEARS. THE
BIGGEST PROBLEM IS GETTING
WATER THROUGH THE DELTA AND I
THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE
ANOTHER BIG HURDLE WE HAVE TO
GET WATER THROUGH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE BIGGEST
THING I SEE IN CALIFORNIA IS WE
HAVE TO WORK ON GETTING WATER
STORAGE. SO WE CAN GET THROUGH
THESE ROUTES WE HAVE DROUGHTS
BUT WE DON'T NEED ANOTHER
HURDLE TO GET WATER THROUGH THE
DELTA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR. DO WE HAVE A MOTION- FOR
A. B. NINE SEVEN NINE. DO YOU
HAVE A MOTION OKAY IT WAS
ROUTED MAKES MOTION WE HAVE A
GOOD MIX THE SECOND COLLECTED
CLOTHES YES SIR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IT'S VERY VERY
CONSIDERATE OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER CONTRACTORS TO
WORRY ABOUT MY DELTA WERE I
LIVE IN AFFLUENT ALL MY ADULT
LIFE. BUT AS YOU'VE MENTIONED
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR A SOLUTION-
WE ARE TOO WE WILL BE ABLE TO
PROTECT OUR ECONOMY IN THE
DELTA OUR WAY OF LIFE. AND BE
ABLE TO PROTECT THE FARMERS
WHO- WHO HAVE A HUGE STAKE IN
INVESTMENT IN THIS. IN THIS
ROLE. BY DOING THIS WE HAVE IT
I DO SIT ON THE DELTA
POTECTION COMMISSION AND DO
MONITOR THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL. THEY HAVE HAD A
TENDENCY TO. WELL KIND OF BEND.
THE RULES WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT-
SEA LEVEL RISE OR SOME KIND OF
OTHER IMPACTS ON THE DELTA WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
JUST A CONSISTENCY AND
EVERYBODY. IS PLAYING ON THE
SAME PLANE THAT'S ALL. AND SO
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT AS MICHAEL
BRODSKY HAD HAD MENTIONED. A
TEN NOT TEN FOOT OF SEA LEVEL
RISE- WOULD BE DRAMATIC IN AN
IMPACTFUL AND OVERTOPPING MOST
OF MY- DELTA LEVEES IN IN THE
LEVEL IN THE IN THE DELTA. AND
SO I'M JUST LOOKING FOR A
SOLUTION TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYTHING IS STUDIED
PROPERLY WITH THE BEST SCIENCE
SO THAT WE CAN GO FORWARD
WHETHER IT IS. MAKING SURE
CONVEYS PROJECT DOES WORKING
CAN'T BE. OF VALUE TO REPAIRS
IF AND IN FACT IT IS APPROVED.
WITH THE BEST SCIENCE.
THEREFORE I REALLY DO REALLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR- AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SIR WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY RUBIO SECOND BY PUPIL
BLAST. AND DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WILL CALL
QUESTION. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO
GARCIA. EDUARDO GARCIA HI
DOLLY. DOLLY NO BENNETT.
BIGELOW FRIEDMAN CRISTINA
GARCIA KALRA LEVIN LEVINE AYE
MERE SEARCHING WHEN RUBIO RUBIO
AYE SALAS SMITH. SMITH NOW WE
HAVE TO DO IT BE ABLE TO DO IT
HI WARD. YOU WILL LEAVE THE
CALL OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO
ADD ON THANK YOU MISTER
TRACKING NUMBERS. NEXXAR
PRESENTER WILL BE SUMMER
ROMMEL'S WHEN THEY BE. ELEVEN
EIGHTY THREE. IT WAS ABOUT A
SURVEY SEGMENTS RUBIO. OR THAT
THE MOTION SECOND ON THE BILL
SO TAKE A FEW MINUTES- TO DO
PRESENTATIONS AS WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL AND
CONFIRM THAT WE WILL BE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS- MISTER CHAIR
HAS RECOMMENDED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS TO REFINE
THE ROLE OF THE PROGRAM IN THE
DESERT CONSERVATION AND TO ADD-
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO GUIDE THE
PROGRAM ITS ACTIVITIES.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY
THREE WILL CREATE A PROGRAM
WITHIN THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
PROJECTS IN THE CALIFORNIA
DESERT TO ADDRESS THE IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE PROTECT
ENHANCE OR RESTORE DESERT
HABITAT AND PROTECT A SACRED
ANCESTRAL LANDS OF THE LOCAL
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THOSE
AREAS. AND PROVIDE PUBLIC
ACCESS OR RECREATIONAL
AMENITIES OR REDUCE THE THREAT
OF WILDFIRE DROUGHT FLOOD. IN
OTHER CATASTROPHE EVENTS. MORE
IMPORTANTLY THIS PROGRAM WILL
BENEFIT THE MANY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WITHIN THE DESERT
REGION. THESE ARE COMMUNITIES
HAVE SUFFERED
DISPROPORTIONATELY FROM ONGOING
ENVIRONMENTAL CRISIS AND THE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE CALIFORNIA DESERT
MERITS INCREASED PUBLIC
ATTENTION. AND INVESTMENT THE
DESERT REGION IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST STILL INTACT ECOSYSTEM
IN THE LOWER FORTY EIGHT
STATES. THESE LANDS PERFORM
CRITICAL ENVIRONMENTAL ROLES
INCLUDING CAPTURING AND STORING
CARBON TO HELP US FIGHT THE
CLIMATE CHANGE CRISIS. THE
DESERT REGION IS ALSO THE
HOMELAND OF NEW NUMEROUS TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES SINCE TIME
IMMEMORIAL WHO CAN BENEFIT FROM
DESERT CONSERVATION PROGRAMS
THAT WOULD PROTECT CULTURAL
RESOURCES- ARTIFACTS. AND AVOID
INADVERTENT DISCOVERY OF NATIVE
AMERICAN REMAINS UNFORTUNATELY
CALIFORNIA FUNDING INITIATIVES
INCLUDES PASSED BONDS HAVE
INVESTED FAR LESS CONSERVATION
FUNDING TO THE DESERT THAN
OTHER AREAS. AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
THREE PROVIDES A SOLUTION TO
THIS PROBLEM BY CREATING A
PROGRAM WITH THE WORK WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD AND FOCUS ON
THE FUNDING IMPORTANT PROJECTS
WITHIN THIS REGION. WITH ME ON
THE PHONE TODAY IN SUPPORT IS
GARY HAHN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE MOJAVE DESERT LAND TRUST
AND CHRISTINE TAMERA OF THE
HISPANIC ACCESS FOUNDATION.
LET'S HAVE THE FIRST WITNESS UP
PRESENT. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
YES WE CAN. OKAY HI- SHERMAN
GARCIA- COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS GERRY
HUN I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE MOJAVE DESERT LAND RUST.
WE'RE DEDICATED TO THE
PROTECTION OF THE MAHABIR
COLORADO DESERT OUR SERVICE
AREA SPANS MORE THAN TWENTY SIX
MILLION ACRES WE PUBLISH OUR
MISSION THROUGH LAND
ACQUISITION MANAGEMENT OUTREACH
AND PUBLIC POLICY WORK TO DATE
WE HAVE CONSERVE MORE THAN
NINETY THOUSAND ACRES. FORMER
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF THE
COACHELLA VALLEY MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY EXPERIENCE FIRST
HAND THE BENEFITS YUBA FOCUSED.
ON TUITION PROGRAM SINCE ITS
INCEPTION THOSE OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN DIRECTED TO
THE COACHELLA VALLEY TO
PRESERVE AND PROTECT ITS
NATURAL LANDSCAPES IN THE
PROVIDE FOR PUBLIC ACCESS. THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT CONSERVATION
PROGRAM WOULD EXTEND THAT SAME
BENEFIT FOR THE REST OF THE
DESERT A MUCH LARGER AREA WITH
MANY CONSERVATION NEEDS.
CALIFORNIA'S CLOSER TO OUR
WORLDWIDE SIGNIFICANCE WITH THE
VAST AND VARIED LANDSCAPES AND
RICH BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY. I
CLINICS SPECIES SUCH AS DESERT
TORTOISES BIGHORN SHEEP IN
JOSHUA TREE ARE IMPLEMENTED
EMBLEMATIC OF THIS DIVERSITY.
THE DESERT'S ARE ALSO. RICH IN
CULTURAL HISTORY. AND THAT'S A
GOOD TO INDIGENOUS PEOPLE.
THERE ARE POPULAR EVEN OUT
RECCA THE- AND TOURISM THE
ECONOMIC ENGINE THE MORNING
BECAUSE OPINION. INCLUDING
DISADVANTAGED AREAS LASTLY
THERE ARE TREMENDOUS CARBON
SINK HELPING IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE SO THERE
ARE DOZENS FACE MANY THREATS
INCLUDING CLIMATE CHANGE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE IN EXOTIC
CLINTON TWO STATIONS. THEY NEED
THE SUPPORT AND FOCUS THAN THE
DESERT CONSERVATION PROGRAM
WOULD PROVIDE ITS ESTABLISHMENT
WOULD ALSO LEVERAGE FEDERAL
FUNDING PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT
OF THE CURRENT PROPOSAL TO
ESTABLISH A CERTAIN THE
LANDSCAPE IN THE DESERT. BUT
THE DEPARTMENTS OF DEFENSE
INTERIOR AND AGRICULTURE I
STRONGLY URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT A. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE WAS WHAT. THE CHRISTINE.
SHARON MEMBERS OF THEY CAN MAKE
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE CAMERA I
AM PARTNERS THE GATES DIRECTOR
HISPANIC FOUNDATION. BANIK AT
THE FUNDATIONIS NATIONAL
NONPROFIT WITH THE MISSION TO
CONNECT LATINOS PARTNERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO IMPROVE LIVES
ENTRY INEQUITABLE SOCIETY.
CREATING THE CALIFORNIA DESERT
CONSERVATION PROGRAM IS
IMPORTANT TO ACCESS
CALIFORNIANS AND LATINOS. MANY
OF THE COMMUNITIES IN THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT OUR LOW
INCOME AND LATINO. COMMUNITIES
AND ALL COMMUNITIES WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THE INVESTMENT
MADE FOR DESERT CONSERVATION
LATINOS IN CALIFORNIA ARE TWCE
AS LIKELY TO LIVE SOMEWHERE
THAT IS NATURE DEPRIVED THAN
WHITE COMMUNITIES. MEANING THEY
HAVE LESS ACCESS TO THE
OUTDOORS AND ARE LESS LIKELY TO
LIVE NEAR STATE AND WELL
MAINTAINED LOCAL PARK. THESE
COMMUNITIES RELY ON THE DESERT
FOR ALL THAT CALIFORNIA HAS TO
OFFER IN THE OUTDOORS FROM
RECREATION TO SIMPLY ENJOYING
THE SCENERY HAVING LET ME TURN
CONSERVE OPEN SPACE NEARBY.
LEAD OUR COMMUNITIES WITH POOR
HEALTH COLVIN NINETEEN SEVERITY
HIGHER STRONGHOLDS. EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES LACK OF RECREATION AND
BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES AND
GREATER VULNERABILITY TO THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE I
HAVE BEEN BLESSED TO HELP WEEK
CAMPING TRIP HI STARGAZING FOR
LATINO COMMUNITIES IN THE
DESERT. THE DESERT REGION
AWKWARD LEVINE AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPERIENCE THE
PEACE FOUND IN NATURE'S BEAUTY
AND PROVIDES AN ESCAPE TO
MOMENTARILY RELIEVED OUR FAMILY
FROM DISTRICT WE ARE ALL
THINKING RIGHT NOW. THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD BRING MUCH
NEEDED RESTORATION INCREASED
PUBLIC ACCESS RECREATION
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND
CLIMATE RESILIENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT IN SHORT IT
WOULD BRING INCREASED EQUITY TO
OUR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
NEARBY WHILE ALSO BENEFITING
THE GLOBAL ENVIRONMENT THAT'S
WHY WE ARE EXCITED TO SPONSOR
THIS LEGISLATION AND STRONGLY
URGE YOU TODAY TO SUPPORT A. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL. CHECK
TO SEE IF THERE ANYONE IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM TO SPEAK AND OF
MEASURE. TONIGHT THERE IS A
ANYONE ANY HERE. VISIT YOU WANT
TO- OR RISK IN FAVOR. IT WILL
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES-
MODERATOR FOR THOSE WISHING TO
SUPPORT. AB. ELEVEN EIGHTY
THREE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT THREE IN
Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING NATALIE MAC- ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING SHERMAN
THIRTY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CAN DELFINO
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU RUN ONE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
UNFIRED MEMBERS. GOOD EVENING
CARE AND MEMBERS TRACY QUINN
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE I'VE
ALSO BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I DON'T HAVE ANYONE
REGISTERED TO SPEAK. AS A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION- I WILL
ASK IF THERE IS ANYONE IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM. IS HE KNOWN
ANYONE HERE IN THE AUDIENCE
WISHING TO ADDRESS- OPPOSITION
TO AB ELEVEN A THREE. SEE NO
ONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
WILL BE BACK TO DIS AND
QUESTIONS- THE MEMBERS FOR OUR
COLLEAGUES. COMMENTS I
APPRECIATE THE BILL I WAS ABLE
TO LISTEN TO IT IN MY OFFICE AT
THE TESTIMONY AND ATTEMPTING TO
DUPLICATE PROJECT BILL ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. IS THERE A
MOTION TO MOVE THEM THE ITEM IT
DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION SO MOVED. MUCH
OF A THREAT. UGH ONE SECOND TO
THE MEASURE. AND DEAD AS I
MENTIONED IT DOESN'T DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THIS COME TO FRUITION
SO. ANY CLOSING COMMENTS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU COMMITTEE AT
THANK YOU TWO OF THE WITNESSES
ARE HERE THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S A VERY MUCH NEEDED- AND
THANK YOU- ENCOURAGE RIVAL. ALL
RIGHT. THIS HAS A TO PASS A
REPLENISH TO APPROPRIATIONS
MOTION THE SECOND FLOOR WE'LL
CALL QUESTION. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO
GARCIA HI EDUARDO GARCIA I
DALI. DALI NO BENNETT HI THEN
IT I BIGELOW. FRIEDMAN CRISTINA
GARCIA. KALRA LEVIN. LEVINE I.
KNEW WHEN. RUBIO RUBIO SALAS
SMITH SMITH NOW VIA PADILLA VIA
DUBAI WARD. LEAVE THE CALL ROLL
CALL OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO
WEIGH IN THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NEXT ITEM
WILL BE BE. FIFTEEN TWELVE BY
OUR COLLEAGUE POWER CAN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I THINK
I'M TOO SHORT THE BEST. CHAIR
PERCENT AB FIFTEEN TWELVE A
BILL THAT WILL PRESERVE A
CRITICAL PIECE OF LAND IN MY
DISTRICT NOTED ALAMEDA TESLA
EXPANSIONARY OR TEST THE PARK
WHICH IS ADJACENT TO THE
CARNEGIE STATE VEHICULAR
RECREATION AREA. IN THE LATE
NINETEEN NINETIES THE-CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
RECREATION PURCHASE THE TEST
THE PARK LAND TO EXPAND OUT THE
CARNEGIE VEHICLE HIT KILLER
PARK OVER THE OBJECTION OF THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY. SCIENTIFIC
STUDIES HAVE LONG DOCUMENTED
THE RARE ECOLOGICAL VALUE OF
THE AREA IT CONTAINS AN
ABUNDANCE OF HIGHLY SENSITIVE
NATURAL RESOURCES INCLUDING
NATIVE BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY A
CRITICAL LINKAGE HABITAT
CORRIDOR UNIQUE VEGETATION
ASSEMBLAGES AND WILDLIFE
HABITATS. I ALSO HOLD IMPORTANT
CULTURAL RESOURCES LIKE THE
HISTORIC TEST THE TOWN IN MINE
COMPLEX INSIGHTS IMPORTANT TO
NATIVE CALIFORNIANS. THE
COMMUNITY IN COUNTY OF ALAMEDA
FOUGHT FOR YEARS TO PROTECT THE
LAND FINALLY IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE JUST RECENTLY A
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE RULED THAT
THE DEPARTMENT'S ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT REPORT WAS INVALID. AS
IT IMPROPERLY CONSTRAINT THE
PROJECT'S OBJECTIVES. IN THE
RULING THE JUDGE DETERMINED
THAT LAND WOULD BEST BE KEPT IN
PRESERVATION FOR PERPETUITY. AB
FIFTEEN TWELVE SIMPLY REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS TO
PRESERVE THE LAND THEY
CURRENTLY OWN IN PERPETUITY
ONCE NINE MILLION DOLLARS OF
NON STATE FUNDS ARE
APPROPRIATED TRANSFERRED OR
DONATED. TO THE OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLE TRUST FUND. WITH
PLENTIFUL EXISTING LAND FOR
WHICH WE USE IT'S ESSENTIAL TO
PRESERVE THIS PRECIOUS NATURAL
RESOURCE AND WILDLIFE WHO CALL
THE PARK HOME. I ALSO WANT TO
POINT OUT THE AMOUNTS THAT THE
STATE HAS SPENT IN LEGAL FEES
SENSE THIS STARTED. BEING
DISPUTED OVER A DECADE AGO AND
THIS WILL ENABLE ONLY START
OVER GIVEN THE RECENT JUDICIAL
DECISIONS SO WE NEED TO STOP
THIS MAKE A DECISION THAT IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST THE
COMMUNITY. AND IN PROCESS
CONTRIBUTES THE GOAL OF THE
GOVERNOR TO PRESERVE 30% OF THE
LAND IN CALIFORNIA BY TWENTY
THIRTY. IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
BY PHONE IS BRANDON DAWSON
INTERMIX ACTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
SIERRA CLUB AND DEER IS ARIO.
BOARD PRESIDENT OF THE
SPIRITUAL PART DISTRICT. SECOND
MUCH OF IT. SOME RUBIO AND
SECULAR MR BENNETT. LET YOUR
WITNESSES- SPEAK. BRANDEN
DAWSON SIERRA CLUB. GOOD
EVENING SURE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BRIAN AND OFTEN ACTING DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA BUT MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS RESERVE IT HAS PARK LAND
HELLO I CAN SEE FOR FUTURE-GENERATIONS WE BELIEVE AB COULD
CONTROL WOULD DO JUST THAT I'M
NOT PRESERVATION COUPLE PARK IN
THE TOP COUNTRY BY COUNTRY
CONSERVATION PRIORITY BUT YOU
SAY REGION AND ARGUED THAT THE
PARK IS LOCATED NATION ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND THERE'S OVERWHELMING
SUPPORT FOR JUST THE
PRESERVATION NOT ONLY
UNIVERSITY PROFESSORS AND
SCIENTISTS BOSTON NATIVE
AMERICAN LEADERS RANCHERS.
CONSERVATION PRESERVATION
GROUPS AND ALSO PUBLIC AGENCIES
SUCH AS THE COUNTY OF ALAMEDA
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
CONSIDERABLE OF MORE
LEGISLATURE OFTEN PASSED
LEGISLATION TO SUPPORT LOCAL
INITIATIVES IN AB TWELVE IS AB
FIFTEEN TWELVE IS A VITAL LOCAL
BUDGET NEED TO RE DESIGNATE
COUPLE PART FOR CONSERVATION
PURPOSES MOREOVER PERMANENT
PRESERVATION OF THE PARK
DIRECTLY MATCH THE STATE
CONSERVATION PROJECT AS WELL.
I'M NOT PRESERVATION OF TULSA
PARK IS DIRECTLY IN LINE WITH
THE GOVERNOR THIRTY BY THIRTY
EXECUTIVE ORDER ISSUED LAST
FALL YOUR PERCENTILE DIVERSITY
PROVIDE CLIMATE CHANGE
RESILIENCY PROTECTS WILDLIFE
CORRIDORS INCREASING. ACCESS TO
NATURE. OKAY STONE FOR LOCAL.
NOW COUNTY EXCEPT WITH LOCAL TO
PAY THE STATE THIRTY ARC IN
PERPETUITY. TWENTY SIXTEEN LOOK
WAITING THAT ALAMEDA OF DOES
LOCAL. FUNDS ALTAMONT LANDFILL
OPENSEARCH FUND PAYS STATE
PARKS AND THE- ONLY TO BE
DIVISION DEPARTMENT BECAUSE OUR
TO ARE. LOOK CONTENT CAN BE
USED TO PAY STATE PARK. CON IS
NOT RETURNING THE LANDERS PARK
AND ORDER TRANCE TO A LOT
CONSERVE. G. AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT. AB FIFTY TWELVE RE
DOESN'T POTENTIAL PARKLAND FOR
CONSERVATION PURPOSES ENCOURAGE.
AND LASTLY I HAD THE NUMBER
MISTER. IN FEBRUARY THIS YEAR A
COURT WILL STATE ARE. CHAMBER
OF THE COW H. STRIKING DAMAGED
PARKS. UP CARD USED VEHICULAR
AREA NOPE. OF TO- SHE BILL. ON
A MOTORIZED RECREATION. THE
COURT ORDERED THOSE PARKING TO
SENATE THE AYE R. WE BELIEVE A
BECAUSE YOU. WALL CREDIT. FOR
THESE REASONS WE CAN. PRICE
THANK YOU. THROUGHOUT THE AREA.
HELLO YES. OKAY GREAT. SIGN AN
EXECUTIVE DIFFICULTY HERE-
CHURCH YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON TO
YOU MEMBERS- ZERO ZERO I'M ON-
DISTRICT FOUR DIRECTORS AND THE
CURRENT. OF THE SPANISH OF
PARKING DIRECTORS ON BEHALF OF
THE APART WOULD EXPRESS OUR OF
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY FIFTY TWELVE
TO PRESERVE THE L. PASS THANK
YOU VERY. OF THE CARNEGIE STATE
VEHICULAR RECREATION AREA WE
ARE PROUD TO JOIN THE NUMBER OF
STATE LOCAL AND ENVIRONMENT
LEADERS INCLUDING ALAMEDA
COUNTY THE CITY OF LIVERMORE
LIVERMORE. AREA RECREATION AND
PARK DISTRICT. WE ALL ARE DOING
THIS- COMMITTEE THE LEGISLATURE.
GOVERNING DIAGRAM IS AMANDA
NATIONALS RESOURCES SECRETARY
WAIT PROPERTY PRESERVE TESTS
SUCH AS A PARK. THE
PARTICIPANTS HISTORIC SAID
PRESENT OF THIS PROPERTY
INCLUDING DESIGNATING ON THE
DISTRICT MASTER PLAN MAP. TOTAL
PARKS RUGGED TERRAIN PROVIDING
USUAL CROSSROADS FOR A WIDE
RANGE OF SENTENCES SPECIES.
RELY ON THIS PROTECTED HABITAT
AS A WILDLIFE CORRIDOR. THE
BEAUTIFUL DIVE DIVERSITY OF
THIS LANDLORDS US TO SAVE IT TO
HONOR THE HERITAGE IS NATIVE
AMERICAN EAGLE PERCHED AND
ALLOW CUSTOMER OWNED PEOPLES
WHO LIVED ON AND CARED FOR
THEIR FAMILIES NOW SOUTH LAMAR
VALLEY ATOP THE RICH.
PRESERVATION HERITAGE IS A
MEANINGFUL MODERATE THAT IS.
THAT THIS WHICH HISTORY IS
IMPORTANT TO US NOW AND FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS. I CAN
CANCEL AS A PRESERVE BUT ALSO
PROVIDE MORE ACCESS TO OPEN
SPACE AND ESSENTIAL OUTDOOR
ACTIVITY OPPORTUNITIES. RECENT
SURVEYS COMMISSIONED BY THE
PARK DISTRICT HAVE REVEALED 96%
OF THE EAST BAY RESPONDENTS
BELIEVE ACCESSIBILITY TO PARKS
AND TRAILS HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPORTANT. FOR
MAINTAINING THE MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH THE SPEAKEASIES
DURING THIS TIME DEMOCRATS.
KIRSTIE COMMITTEE ON WATERPARKS
AND WILDLIFE TO APPROVE EIGHTY
FIFTEEN TWELVE. AND IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE DEVELOP A
PATHWAY FOR TO PRESERVE THIS
IMPORTANT ECOLOGICALLY RICH
PROPERTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU WE'LL ASK A TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY. INDIVIDUALS
WANTING TO WEIGH IN AND SUPPORT
IN THE CONFERENCE ROOM. SEE NO
ONE ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE. NO
ONE WILL OPEN UP THE LIGHTS- IN
SUPPORT OKAY AS YOU WISH
FIFTEEN TWELVE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN TWELVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE A- ABOUT FIFTEEN IN Q. WHO
TWO ONE ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS RECALL
MASTRODONATO WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
NOT ONE WHICH IS FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS DEAL
SHOWER I SUPPORT THE- BILL AB
ONE FIVE ONE TWO AND I'M WITH
THE ORGANIZATION NAME TO THE
HILL HIKERS LIVERMORE. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU KNOW
QUANTITY AND REPRESENTING
ALAMEDA CREEK ALLIANCE IN
CALIFORNIA WILDLIFE FEDERATION
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN TWELVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS CHAD ARE CREE
FROM THE- CALIFORNIA NATIVE
GRASSLANDS ASSOCIATION- I'M ON
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS. AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB. TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND WE URGE
YOU TO PASS IT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I WON SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL IN ROCKPORT I
REPRESENT EAST ALAMEDA COUNTY
RANCHERS I'M A TOTAL ROAD
RESIDENT AND I'M ALSO A
DIRECTOR ON THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
RESOURCE CONSERVATION BOARD AND
I COME OUT IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A BI FIFTEEN TWELVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEMENI'S ROBBER ALL AGAIN-
LONGTIME EAST BAY RESIDENT THAT
LIVES NEWSPAPER THIRTY YEARS
AND I ALSO SIT ON LEGAL
CALIFORNIA'S CITIES- REVENUE
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE- AND I'M
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN TWELVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WON
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
DICK SNYDER SPEAKING FOR THE
ALTAMONT LANDFILL OPEN SPACE
COMMITTEE WHICH HAS THE NINE
MILLION CALL FOR A BI FIFTEEN
TWELVE AND SUPPORTS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RUN ONE
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS WILLIAM HARPER THANK
PRESIDENT OF THE ALONI STUDY
WHICH SERVES SOUTHERN AND
EASTERN ALAMEDA COUNTY MAYOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI FIFTEEN
TWELVE. THANK YOU I WON FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS TAMERA ROYCE- WITH FRIENDS
OF OPEN SPACE AND VINEYARDS IN
DELIVER MARIN TRI VALLEY AREA
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RUN ONE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS BETH HORSBURGH
I'M WITH THE EAST BAY CHAPTER
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT ONE SIX NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT ONE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT ONE TO
SIX TO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MANY MEMBERS-
MY NAME IS JENNIFER SPENCE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE FIGHTING
AMERICAN INDIANS IN LIVERMORE
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN TWELVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME'S WILL BOLTON PRESIDENT
OF THE PARK HERITAGE GUILD
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN TWELVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CELESTE
GARAMENDI IN ADDITION TO THE
SUPPORT OF THE FRIENDS OF
CASTLE PARK ALLIANCE I'M ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
GREENBELT ALLIANCE. REGIONAL
PARKS ASSOCIATION AND SAN
JOAQUIN AUDUBON SOCIETY IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE FIVE ONE TWO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WANT
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS JOHN LEWIS I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE SENATE FINANCE
COMMITTEE TO COMPLETE THE
REFUGE AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
SIXTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HELLO MY NAME IS KATHERINE
BOXER FROM THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT
ON THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
AB DE SUPPORT A. B. FIFTEEN
TWELVE IN THE STRONGER. WAY
POSSIBLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RUN ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY ONE SIX FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY ONE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
ARTHUR HOLES REPRESENTING THE
FRIENDS OF THE- ROYA AND THE
FRIENDS OF SPRING SPRING TOWN
PRESERVE WE ENTHUSIASTICALLY
SUPPORT AB FIFTEEN TWELVE.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER SHARE MY NAME IS KIM
DELFINO I'M REPRESENTING
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL ASK- I BELIEVE WE HAVE
DIANA MEAD THAT WILL BE
TESTIFYING AGAINST. THE
MEASURE. SO IF SHE IS ON THE
LINE AND WE'LL ASK THAT SHE
BEGAN. I AM ON THE LINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CHAIRED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR GRANTING
ME THIS TIME TO ADDRESS YOU
TODAY. MY NAME IS DIANA MEANS
THE CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL IS
MY SENATOR. MANY OF YOU
REPRESENT DISTRICTS DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THIS BILL. YOU KNOW
YOU'RE DISTRICTS EVERYONE OF
THEM HAS WONDERFUL PART. SOME
OF THEM STATE THAT DO NOT OFFER
OHB RECREATION OPPORTUNITIES.
EACH OF YOU HAS RECEIVED THE
CARNEGIE ASSESSMENT THE
DOCUMENT INCLUDES THE HISTORY
OF CARNEGIE STATE VEHICULAR
RECREATION AREA WITH A FOCUS ON
THE ALAMEDA CATHOLIC PENSION
PARCEL. THIS IS A MUCH
DIFFERENT ISSUE THAN THE ONE
THAT HAS BEEN DESCRIBED OVER
TWENTY YEARS AGO TWELVE MILLION
OHB TRUST FUND DOLLARS WERE
INVESTED FOR THE CARNEGIE STR
EIGHT EXPANSION. TWELVE MILLION
WAS NOT A ONE AND DONE PALE
DURING THE LAST TWENTY THREE
YEARS STATE PARK SIX THE SAN
FRANCISCO WATER DISTRICTS
MISTAKE COSTING ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION. MITIGATION CONTINUES
TODAY OF AN EARLY TWENTIETH
CENTURY MINING OPERATION
ARCHAEOLOGICAL SITES ARE
CATALOGUED AND PROTECTED ALL
FUTURE PROJECTS REQUIRE PUBLIC
INPUT STUDIES AND APPROVAL. B.
O. H. MBA OR DIVISION OF STATE
PARKS IS COMMITTED THE FUNDING
TO PRESERVE AND PROTECT WILL
RESPONSIBLY DEVELOPING MULTIPLE
USERS ACCESS. ON OUR GOVERNOR
THIRTY EXECUTIVE ORDER STATE
PARKS INCLUDING CARNEGIE SBRA
OUR EXISTING CONSERVATION AREA.
POINT OF INTEREST THOUGH
RANCHES INCLUDING THE
NEIGHBORING PARCELS CAN BE
CONSIDERED ELIGIBLE FOR THE
THIRTY THIRTY CRITERIA. SH THE
CURRENT PARK HAS NOT AS IS
REPEATEDLY ALLEGED IN A DROP IN
VISITORS THERE WAS A DROP FROM
200-092-2000 TWELVE. DURING THE
RECESSION. THE CURRENT PARK IS
AMAZING FOR EXPERIENCE
MOTORCYCLE RIDERS THERE IS NO
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LARGEST
GROWING SEGMENT OF OHB THE
FAMILY ORIENTED VIEW T. V. NORD
THEIR MOTORIZED ACCESS. TO
WOODED TRAILS FOR MOBILITY
LIMITED LIMITED DISABLED A
PROTECTED CLASS. THE EXPANSION
WILL OFFER BOTH AND MORE ONE
THIRD OF THE AREA IS DEDICATED
TO BUFFER ZONE. NONE OF THE
MEANDERING TRAILS WILL BE
VISIBLE TO NEIGHBORING PROPERTY.
WHY DOESN'T THE OHB GROUP FUND
SIMPLY FIND A MORE SUITABLE
PLACE FOR THIS RECREATION.
PLEASE TELL US WHERE IN THE
GREATER BAY AREA THE PARKING
DIRECTLY WE CREATED. THIS
ARTICLE WAS PURCHASED AND
MITIGATED EXPRESSLY TO
SUSTAINABLY PROVIDE OPPORTUNITY
FOR WHAT IS NOT AVAILABLE AT
THE EXISTING PARK. ACTUATED
NORTH OF CARNEGIE S. B. R.
EIGHT R. LAWRENCE LABORATORY
THANK THREE HUNDRED AND A GUN
RANGE TO THE SOUTH EXCEPT BY A
STATE MAINTAINED ROAD TO THE
PARK IS STANFORD RESEARCH
INSTITUTE. ALSO ACCESS BY THAT
EASEMENT IS THE CATTLE RANCHING
AND DELETE ELK HUNTING
ENTERPRISE. THIS PARK NEIGHBOR
IT KNOWLEDGE IN WRITING AT TIME
OF PURCHASE THAT THE
ACQUISITION PARCEL WAS TO
EXPAND- H. B. OPPORTUNITY. A
COPY OF THIS DOCUMENT IS IN THE
REPORT FOR YOUR REFERENCE. THIS
IS IPORTANT AT THIS NEIGHBORS
ASSOCIATED WITH LITIGATION
AGAINST CARNEGIE S. B. R. A. N.
D. ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THERE WILL BE
PRESIDENT THAT WITH THIS
LEGISLATION MR CALL ME IN THE
STATE ON THE SIDE OF THAT SIDE
AND RIPPED A FEW COULD. BEGIN A
WRAP UP YOUR TESTIMONY PLEASE.
YOU EXCEEDED THE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU. I'M SORRY I
UNDERSTOOD IT WAS FOR. THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD YOU SIR PARKS
DECISION MAKING AND MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY GOVERNOR NEWSOM MADE
THIS OBSERVATION IN ITS TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN VETO OF AB
TEN EIGHTY SIX. THE GOVERNOR
DID NOT MISUNDERSTAND THE BILL.
THE FACT THE SCIENCE IN THE
ENVIRONMENT ALL ARE CHECKED OFF
IN THE STATE PARKS HOME.
FINALLY MY SENATOR HAS STATED
THAT LEGISLATION IS NEEDED TO
END COSTLY LAWSUITS. SENATOR
GLAZERS THE AFOREMENTIONED
NEIGHBOR A LAWYER BY TRADE HAS
MADE IT CLEAR HE WILL CONTINUE
WORKING TO ELIMINATE- H. B.
FROM THE VALLEY INCLUDING THE
EXISTING PARK. THE END OF THE
LAWSUITS WILL COME WHEN YOU
ALLOW STATE PARKS TO DO THE JOB
CALIFORNIANS HAVE INSTRUCTED
THEM TO DO AND THIS ATTEMPT AT
LEGISLATIVE NIMBYISM. THANK YOU
THANK YOU LAST TO SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOMS. ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE THE C. NO ONE WILL
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES. AGAIN
PLEASE. OKAY SO WILL OPEN UP
PHONE LINES FOR THOSE I WANTED
TO REGISTER OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE WE ASK THAT YOU STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION PLEASE. MODERATOR IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FIFTEEN TWELVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WHAT DO I WON SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS ED FILL THEM WITH THE SAN
DIEGO OFFERED COALITION AND WE
OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN TWELVE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL-
BRING THE ITEM BACK TO US MY
COLLEAGUES HERE. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS. OR EMOTIONS.
WE ALREADY HAVE WE HAVE A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WE DO HAVE
A MOTION ALREADY CAN THE MAN
WHO. CHECKED ALL RIGHT. I
FIGURE THIS WILL BE A NEW
MISTER BENNETT THE CORRECT
OKAY. I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU MISTER TERRY TRYING
TO ADDRESS ONE THING THEM IF
NEED SAID. WHICH IS THE BY NO
MEANS IS THIS EFFORT TRYING TO
OR OES IT INTEND TO CHANGE
REDUCE OR DO ANYTHING TO THE
EXISTING OFFERED VEHICLE PARK
THAT'S LOCATED AT CARNEGIE THIS
MERELY TALKS ABOUT THE
EXPANSIONARY WHICH AS I
MENTIONED. HAS FOR OVER A
DECADE BEEN SITTING VACANT WELL
WE SPENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
LITIGATION IS A STATE TRYING
DECIDE WHAT TO DO WITH THAT.
AND SO- I WAS ACTUALLY JUST OUT
THERE LAST WEEK SEEING PEOPLE
RECORD IN CARNEGIE AND THEY
HAVE THIS BILL WILL CONTINUE TO
ALLOW THAT RECREATION- AND WE
REALLY ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
AREA THAT HAS BEEN ON TOUCHING
CONTINUES TO BE IN TOUCH AS
RESULT OF THE ONGOING
LITIGATION. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE ALL RIGHT THIS IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH CAN RUBIO AND
THEN. MOVED TO SECOND THE BILL-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL. QUESTION
NUMBER IS THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA I
EDUARDO GARCIA HI DOLLY DOLLY
NO BENNETT. BENNETT I BIGELOW
FRIEDMAN CRISTINA GARCIA KALRA
LEVIN LEVINE AYE MURATSUCHI NO
ONE RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SMITH
SMITH NO VIA PADILLA VIA
PADILLA I WARD. THANK YOU
MISTER TRIMMERS THANK YOU WE'LL
KEEP TIA ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO WAY AND I'M GOING TO
ASK AT THIS TIME- ARE VICE
CHAIRS PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
MR FLORA. AND SO LASCARS AND
THEN- WE ARE GETTING CLOSE TO
THE FINISH LINE HERE MEMBERS WE
KALRA MISTER VIA BELOW UP. WHO
WILL BE PRESENT AS WELL. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM
PRESENTING AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
FOUR ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLORA. FIRST THE AUTHOR
ACCEPTS THE COMMITTEES PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS AB
ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR CLARIFIES A
PUBLIC AGENCY REGULATING
RESERVOIRS USED FOR
AGRICULTURAL PURPOSES ARE TO BE
TREATED IN THE SAME MANNER AS
PRIVATE REGULATORY FACILITIES.
REAGAN REGULATING RESERVOIR AS
A SMALL RESERVOIR CONSTRUCTED
TO STORE WATER THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE SPILL OVER FROM CANAL
SYSTEMS CURRENTLY THE
CALIFORNIA WATER CODE.
RECOGNIZES THE BENEFIT OF THESE
PRACTICES IN CLEARLY STATES THE
STRUCTURE USED TO STORE WATER
FOR AGRICULTURAL PURPOSES IS X.
THEM DEAD FROM STATE
REGULATORY. JUSTICE
JURISDICTION EXCUSE ME HOWEVER
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES HAS ADOPTED
CONTRARY TO ITS PRIOR PRIOR
VIEW INTERPRETATION OF EXISTING
LAW THAT EXCLUDES PUBLIC
ENTITIES FROM TAKING PART IN
AGRICULTURE USE EXEMPTION. AB
ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR WOULD ENABLE
PUBLIC ENTITIES TO CONSTRUCT
AND MAINTAIN REGULATORY.
REGULATING RESERVOIRS TO STORE
AND CONVEY YOUR GEISHA WATER IN
THE SAME MANNER AS PRIVATE
AGRICULTURAL ENTITIES ON THE
PHONE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AS MR
CHAD. TEN KEY FROM MODESTO
IRRIGATION DISTRICT IN RANDY
HOPKINS. RIGHT WHEN THIS IS THE
PERCEIVED. GOOD EVENING- I'M
CHAD TAKEN WITH THE MODESTO
IRRIGATION DISTRICT THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO NEEDED
TO ADDRESS YOU TODAY-
REGULATING RESERVOIRS ARE ONE
OF THE PRINCIPAL TOOLS
AVAILABLE TO PUBLIC AGENCIES
FOR IMPROVING WATER USE
EFFICIENCY. AND AS EVERYONE
KNOWS THAT- CALIFORNIA FINDS
ITSELF IN THE ENTIRE STREETS
RIGHT NOW WITH REGARDS TO WATER.
SIXTEEN SIX THOUSAND FOR THE
WATER CODE- PROVIDES AN
EXEMPTION- AS- AND- ASSEMBLY
DOLLY DUNN NOTED AND AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FOUR CLARIFIES THAT THE
EXEMPTION APPLIES BOTH TO BOTH
PRIVATELY AND PUBLICLY OUR
RESERVOIRS AND WHAT I WANT TO
POINT OUT IS THAT IT PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL SAFETY CRITERIA FOR
PUBLIC AGENCIES LIKE IT MIGHT
BE TO BE GRANTED AN EXCEPTION
STATUS- DAMS. THE SCREEN OR
RIVER THE INFLOWS CONTROLLED
AND THE RESERVOIRS ONLY OPERATE
WHEN AN IRRIGATION DISTRICT IS
RUNNING WATER THROUGH ITS
CONVEYANCE SYSTEM. WHAT THE
ONSET OF THE WATER CONSERVATION
ACT OF TWO THOUSAND NINE AND
STIGMA PUBLICATION SEEDS ALL
OVER THE STATE INCLUDING THE
BEST OF YOUR NATION DISTRICT
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF PLANNING
AND IMPLEMENTING PROJECTS SUCH
AS THE USE AND THE LEGISLATION
WILL HELP. GET THOSE PROJECTS
BUILT SOONER IMPROVING OUR
ABILITY TO CONSERVE WATER IN
RECHARGE AQUIFERS. BENEFITING
CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE. THANK
YOU. THE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME MY NAME'S RANDY
HOPKINS WITH PROVOST APPROACH-
CONSULTING GROUP I'M A VICE
PRESIDENT AND PRINCIPAL
ENGINEER AND I'M HERE AS A
SOMEONE WHO DESIGNED A NUMBER
OF THESE FACILITIES TO PROVIDE
ANSWERS TO COMMITTEE MAY HAVE A
ABOUT THE OF THE- THESE
FACILITIES. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK TO SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY OTHER FOLKS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
TELECONFERENCE ROOM. HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS. ON THE PHONE
LINES WILL OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT SCREEN
Q. WILL GO TO ONE ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. JAMIE
MINOR BE HELPED. IRRIGATION
DISTRICT WE SUPPORT THE BILL
AND CRAIG AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE AS THE FILM
PROGRESSES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS JULIE HALL AT THE
CESSATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU RUN ONE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS CANDOR DIJO THE
WITH THE CLUB WELCOME GROUP ON
BEHALF THE KINGS RIVER
CONSERVATION DISTRICT AND THE
KINGS RIVER WATER ASSOCIATION.
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I DON'T HAVE ANYONE
REGISTERED HERE TO SPEAK- OR
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION- WILL ASK. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MOTION SERVICE
SEGMENTS LEVINE. WE DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY REGISTERED OFFICE TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM. NOPE NO ONE
HERE PRESIDENT. OVER THE PHONE
LINES ANYONE WISHING TO READ
SHOP POSITION MODERATOR. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
PERFECT THANK YOU WE ARE GOING
TO BRING YOU BACK TO DíAS TO
DO A MOST SECOND. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS THE NONE. ALLOW ASKED
IF YOU ARE CLOSE SPECT WESTERN
I'VE A THANK YOU. THIS IS DO
PASS APPROPRIATIONS AND
SECRETARY. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA
HI EDUARDO GARCIA HI DOLLY
DOLLY I'D BENNETT BENNETT I
BIGELOW FRIEDMAN CRISTINA
GARCIA. KALRA LEVINE LEVINE I
MEMBERS SU CHI WHEN RUBIO RUBIO
AYE SALAS SMITH SMITH I HAVE TO
DO IT WOULD BE A BIG DEAL I
WARD. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE OUR OTHER COLLEAGUES TO BE
APPLIED T. PRESENT AB THREE
FIFTY. MOTION BY MISTER SMITH
SECOND BY THE VICE CHAIR DOES
EVERYTHING ABOUT US. RECTAL
THANK YOU MEMBERS- A. B. THREE
FIFTY CREATES THREE YEAR
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES GRANTS
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
HELP CREATE. CONSERVATION
MANAGEMENT PLANS FOR LANDLORDS
AND FARMERS THESE THESE PLANS
WILL ADDRESS THE IN IMPACTS ON
THE AGRICULTURAL PROPERTIES
FROM THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
SIGMA- WE HAD GOOD
CONVERSATIONS. WITH ALL THE
PARTIES TO EXPAND THIS GRANT
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE BASIN ACROSS
THE ENTIRE STATE. AND TO
CONTINUE THE WORK ON THESE
AMENDMENTS- WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IS- KATIE PATTERSON CALIFORNIA
POLICY MANAGEMENT MANAGER FOR
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST. RIGHT
PLEASEEIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND AN
ELECTRIC CHAIR GOOD EVENING
MANY MEMBERS AGAIN MY NAME IS
KATIE PATTERSON AND THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY MANAGER FOR
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST AND
WILL PROBABLY MONSTER EIGHTY
THREE FIFTY EIGHTEEN NIGHTS
FARMERS IN ENVIRONMENTALISTS
AND POLICYMAKERS IN DEVELOPING
PRACTICAL SLUTIONS LIKE.
EIGHTY THREE FIFTY EQUITEC
FARMLAND. AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
SO WHERE ARE WE NOW WATER
SCARCITY A CHANGING CLIMATE NEW
REGULATIONS AND GROWING
POPULATION ARE JUST SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES FACING FARMERS AND
FARMLAND IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
AGRICULTURAL REGION NAFTA'S
WORK IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
WE FOUND THAT THE HIGH QUALITY
FARMLAND. THE MOST PRODUCTIVE
VERSATILE AND RESILIENT WHAT
THE **** THEY'RE RELIABLE WATER
SOURCE IS VERY LIMITED WITH
ONLY 9% OF THE ROUGHLY SIX
MILLION ACRES OF IRRIGATED
FARMLAND IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY BEING UP HIGH QUALITY
AND EXPERIENCING LOW WATER
STRESS. RIGHT TO THE STATE.
CAPITOL UP. STATEWIDE
GROUNDWATER. IS ESTIMATED TO BE
IN THE RANGE OF TWO MILLION TO
TWO AND A HALF MILLION ACRE
FEET THE CARD HERE. AND
ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA SOME
INDICATIONS ARE THAT NEARLY 40%
OF THE CURRENT SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY CROPLAND OR SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
LAND. MAY NEED TO BE FOLLOWED
OR RETIRE TO BRING THE
GROUNDWATER AQUIFERS IN THE
BALLOT. ISSUE WOULD HAVE AN
ECONOMIC COST OF APPROXIMATELY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
ACCORDING TO KEEP YAKKING.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THERE WILL BE
SUBSTANTIAL COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH ACHIEVING SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT. BUT THE
LONG TERM ECONOMIC IMPACT WOULD
BE CONSIDERABLY GREATER THAT
GROUNDWATER USERS NOT MANAGED
FIFTEEN ATHLETES AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IS NOT. MADE
AVAILABLE FOR CONSERVATION
PLANNING. ACROSS THE STATE JUST.
WITH DEVELOPING AN ON FARM
CONSERVE PLANTS AND REACHING
THE WATER USE REDUCTION GOALS
OF THE ACT WE RECOGNIZE THE
MANY CASES SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS MAY
REQUIRE INTENSIVE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. INCLUDING LANGUAGE
SUPPORT TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF STIGMA. THIS
BILL WOULD ENCOURAGE INNOVATION
AND ALTERNATIVELY ECONOMICALLY
VIABLE APPROACHES TO
AGRICULTURAL LAND MANAGEMENT.
IN SIXTEEN UNNECESSARY
UNNECESSARY FOLLOWING.
INCREASING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND CONSERVATION PLANNING FOR
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCERS
ESSENTIAL TO HELP THE MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITY THE
SUCCESSFUL. IN ACHIEVING THE
GOAL. AND IN CHEATING THE STATE
OFFICIALS CALLED STAFF PERSON
ASSISTING THE PROGRAM WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT WHEN FARMS AND
RANCHES GEN OUR ADVANTAGE FOR
MULTIPLE BENEFITS. TO HELP
PROTECT MOST VALUABLE AND
PRODUCTIVE AGRICULTURAL LAND
PROTECT KEY SURFACE AND
GROUNDWATER SUPPLIES IN SUPPORT
CRITICAL HABITAT FOR FISH AND
WILDLIFE. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST NINE BUT-
I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I DON'T HAVE A
SECOND TO A WITNESS REGISTERED
TO. SPEAK US. TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE CONFERENCE ROOM.
ANYONE HERE THE ALL. WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES MY- IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE FIFTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT THREE IN Q. OVERLAND ONE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
SAID NAGA ON BEHALF OF RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE NINETY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
JANEY GIRL ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE ONE SEVEN EIGHT
PLEASE GO OUT. WHY IN ONE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ABOUT
ROBINSON ON OUR- HE OF MADERA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME RIGHT WE WILL ASK
THEM. I DON'T HAVE ANYONE
REGISTERED TO- PROVIDE US
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY SO I WILL
ASK TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
THE CONFERENCE ROOM. NO ONE
HERE IN THE AUDIENCE. THE NON
THEN WILL OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION TO AB DE
FIFTY. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB THREE FIFTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. OVERALL I WON
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SLIDE ONE SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NINETY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I COULD AFTERNOON OR
EVENING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
PROGRAM A CARBOXYL ELLIOT
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
COMPANY GROW OUR COALITION-
AGAIN ALSO NOTE THAT THE
COMPANY GROW WATER COLLECTION
HAS THAT IS GOING. TO MAKE YOUR
DECISION. I GOT CUT OFF AND DID
YOU HEAR ABOUT THE AUTHOR
MENTION- THAT COULD NOT THAT
MANY THAT HE COMMITTED TO TAKE
AND AGRICOLE. PROBABLY TO GO
BUT IT'S ELEVEN ARE GOING TO BE.
YEAH GROWN COLD WON'T.
INITIALLY FROM THE POOR- IF YOU
THINK FROM A PUDDLE OF AMENDED
TO THE PARKING- AND- THE MANY
PART. THANK PROGRAM AVAILABLE.
TO CRITICALLY OVER BE NOT YET
BEATEN BUDGET. ALLOCATION
VALLEY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO COMMENTS THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT NUMBER YOU BACK TO THE
OTHER SIDE IN THE ARE FOR OUR
CALL. THERE IS A MOTION AND A
SECOND. AND IF THERE AREN'T ANY
QUESTIONS AND WE WILL HAVE TO
PASS RECOGNITION CORPORATIONS.
MOTIONS CAN FROM THE LEFTOVER
OF SMITH WAS LIVING. THE
COMMENTS I'D JUST LIKE TO ASK
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IRA
THANK YOU SIR AFTER. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I
DALI. DALI AYE BENNETT AYE
BENNETT AYE BIGELOW FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I'D KALRA. KALRA HI LEVINE.
LEVINE I MURATSUCHI KNOW WHEN.
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SMITH
SMITH I'D BE A PRODUCER HI THE
OF TO DO AYE WARD. THANK YOU
WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO OUT ON NEXT
PRESENTER WILL BE MISTER KALRA
SB THIRTY. AFTER THIS BILL WE
HAVE A ONE LEFT. AND WE'RE
GONNA SEE IF WE COULD GET. A
BRING BRING THAT TO OUR MISTER
FRIEDMAN'S ATTENTION. WE HAVE
ABOUT ONE BILL THAT WOULD BE
MRS MISTREATMENT. WILL LET HER
KNOW THAT- SHE'S UP AFTER THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AB THIRTY WOULD AFFIRM
THAT ACCESS TO NATURE AND ITS
BENEFITS OR HUMAN RIGHTS AND
WOULD ALSO DIRECTS STATE
AGENCIES TO INCORPORATE
CONSIDERATION OF THAT RIGHT.
INTO EXISTING POLICIES
REGARDING ACCESS TO THE
OUTDOORS. ESPECIALLY FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE OR HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN NATURE
DEPRIVED. ALL NATURE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN ARRESTED FOR PEOPLE ACROSS
MANY BACKGROUNDS THE PANDEMIC
IS ALSO HIGHLIGHTED INEQUITIES
AND ACCESSING CLEAN AND SAFE
OUTDOOR SPACES. AND WORST CASE
SCENARIOS THERE'S A LACK OF
ACCESS TO THE SPACES ALL
TOGETHER. BEING BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS THE MANY BENEFITS OF
NATURE IS NECESSARY FOR THE
MENTAL AND PHYSICAL HEALTH. OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS AND THE
OVERALL WILL BE IT BEING OF
PEOPLE. BUT STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT PEOPLE OF COLOR FAR LESS
LIKELY TO HAVE ACCESS TO
NATURE. A 70% A LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES TODAY LIVE IN
NATURE DEPRIVED AREAS I CAN SEE
THAT MYSELF. I IN MY OWN
DISTRICT IN PARTS OF SAN JOSE-
WHERE THERE ARE NEIGHBORHOODS
WHERE YOU HAVE TO. WALK FOR A
VERY LONG TIME TO GET TO ANY
KIND OF OPEN SPACES OR EVEN
PARKS. SIMILARLY INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES LIVING IN RURAL
AREAS HAVE LIKEWISE SUFFER
DISPROPORTIONATELY FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL DEGRADATION. AND
DISPLACEMENT. AS A DISTRICT
DESTRUCTION OF NATURE EXCEL
REYES OF UNPRECEDENTED RATES
DUE TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND OTHER
FACTORS MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES WILL CONTINUE TO
BEAR MORE OF THE NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES. IF CALIFORNIA
WANTS TO CONTINUE TO LEAD ON
CRITICAL ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES A
MUST NOT LEAVE AUDIBLE
COMMITTEES BEHIND ESPECIALLY
DURING A TIME WHEN THEY NEED TO
BE LIFTED UP THE MOST. AB
THIRTY PUTS ACCESS TO THE
OUTDOORS AND NATURE FRONT AND
CENTER AND THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT WE HAVE A DIFFERENT MORE
INCLUSIVE APPROACH TO WHO GETS
TO EXPERIENCE NATURE AND ITS
BENEFITS. WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
PHYSICAL ACCESS TO AMENITIES
SUCH AS PARKS BEACHES REGIONAL
OPEN SPACES OF WILDERNESS
AREAS. OR BY BEING ABLE TO
ENJOY CLEAN AIR CLEAN WATER AND
OTHER BENEFITS OF A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT. AB THIRTY WOULD
AFFIRM THAT ACCESS TO NATURE
AND AS BENEFITS ARE HUMAN
RIGHTS. AND BY ADOPTING AB
THIRTY CALIFORNIA BECOME THE
FIRST DAY DECLARE THAT ACCESS
TO NATURE IS HUMAN RIGHTS
SUDDEN IMPORTING. SETTING AN
IMPORTANT EXAMPLE FOR THE REST
OF THE NATION. BUT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES CAN
BENEFIT ACTIVELY. ACTIVELY IN
OUR ONGOING EFFORTS TO PROTECT
NATURE. THIS BILL ENJOYS BROAD
SUPPORT FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
ADVOCATES AND OUTDOOR
RECREATION GROUPS INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES AND PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. INCLUDING NURSES
AND PHYSICIANS. ACCESS TO
PUBLIC LAND H. AND A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT SHOULD BE A RIGHT
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS I'M
GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO CHAMPION
THIS BILL IN PARTNERSHIP WITH.
AUDUBON CALIFORNIA AZUL AND
LATINO OUTDOORS. SPECTER HAS
ARRIVED I HAVE A- THANK YOU SO
MUCH. APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH OF MEMBERS AND- THE
CHAIR. OF THE ONE WITNESS I
HAVE IS ONE OF THE MOST. OF THE
MATERNAL ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY FOR THE OF ON
CALIFORNIA. ALL RIGHT PLEASE
VISIT. KEVIN WELL GOOD EVENING
CARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY. I NEVER THOUGHT I'D BE
DONE ALSO TO DIRECTOR OF POLICY
FOR A BUNCH CALIFORNIA. WHERE
PRO COSPONSORED WITH THE
TELEPHONE OF THE ORGANIZATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS DEDICATED TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
ENJOY EQUITABLE ACCESS TO THE
OUTDOORS IN NATURE. OF THE BOOK
ONLINE CALIFORNIANS ARE CO
SPONSORS- COULD PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE IN WORKING WITH YOU.
THE PHILIPPINE AND OUTDOOR
ACTIVITY BECAUSE OF THIS IT
EXPERIENCE WE UNDERSTAND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO CONNECT
PEOPLE WITH NATURE ENSURE THAT
THE- BENEFITS ARE ENJOYED BY
EVERYONE. UNFORTUNATELY AS
MISTER KALRA SAID- OUTDOOR
pSPACES ARE STILL NOT EQUITABLE
EQUALLY ACCESSIBLE TO EVERYONE.
A FACT THAT CODEPENDENT BECAUSE
MICHELIN BOXLIGHT CORP IN
NINETEEN HAS SHOWN US THAT.
OXYGENATOR IS NECESSARY FOR
MENTAL HEALTH AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH WHILE PEOPLE AND THEN
MAKE FURTHER ILLUSTRATED THAT
DUE TO THE HISTORICAL BASIS
SEGREGATIONIST IN EQUITY.
PEOPLE OF COLOR OR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
CONTINUE TO SUFFER FROM ON
EQUAL ACCESS. TO NATURE AND ITS
BENEFITS. THE RECENT REPORT BY
THE- OCCUPIED NATION AND THAT
THE FOR A PROGRESS ON THE
COMMUNITIES COLOR A THREE. MORE
LIKELY THAN THEIR WHITE CAL
DILEMMA YOUR HI JERRY. AND 70%
OF LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES THAT
TO MAKE. ASSEMBLY WELL THE FATE
HAD PROGRESS TOWARDS PROMOTING
BUT WHAT JUST ALL THAT- MUCH
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE.
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO WITH A
VALUE BY STOP KERR OF THE
DIRECT INVESTMENT TO INCREASE
ACT. AND PRIVATE THE VOICES
NEED PRIORITY LOOKING CALL AND
THIS INDUSTRY. AND ECONOMICALLY
TO COMMUNITIES BOTH IN RURAL
AND OR READ. I TELL LOOKS
TACKLE ISSUE THE RESERVE AND OF
COURSE PARK IN MY RECOGNIZE
AFTER I'M GOING TO BACK MAKE
SURE I'LL TELL OTHERS HAVE IN
THE FOR ACCESS NATURE TO BANISH.
THIS BILL WOULD DECLARE TO
PAULA OF THE THAT IN IN THE%
BENEFIT ARE RIGHTS INEQUITABLE
ACCESS TO GREEN SPACES IN
NATURE CREEK HEALTH DISPARITIES
AND OTHER INEQUITIES. THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE RELEVANT. STATE
AGENCIES TO INCORPORATE THAT.
STATE POLICY WILL REVISED OR
DAY. ASSEMBLY COLLEGE BRING.
ARE CRACKED HERE YEAH. THAT ARE
PERTINENT TO THE- ACTIVE THE
NATURE OF THE HUMAN RIGHTS THIS
IS A MESSAGE THAT IT IS NOT.
FIRST STEP IT CLOSE GET IN MANY
MAJOR TO CRY DEPRIVE YOU NEED.
AND IT ALSO HELP THE ABOUT THIS
GOAL TO PROTECT BIODIVERSITY
REPORTER ST CLIMATE GOALS SET
UNDER FROM DICK. BECOME BORDER
WE BELIEVE IN THE BILL WE
BELIEVE WE CAN MAKE A-
DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S LIVES
AND WE BELIEVE WE CAN DO IT
TOGETHER ANDFOR THOSE REASONS.
THAT WE RESPECTFULLY URGE AND I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU- NO WONDER
WHAT. BUT WILL CHECK WITH THE
COMPANY ROOM IF ANYONE WANTS
TO. SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE
MEASURE. ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE. WILL OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR FOR THOSE
ONES SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY. Q. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WHAT TO LINE ONE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT
ONE ONE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD EVENING NATALIE MAC
CALLING ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
NATURE CONNECTION CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION LOS
ANGELES NEIGHBORHOOD LAND TRUST
BECAUSE THE REGION OF THE STATE
DISTRICT IN NATURE FOR ALL IN
SUPPORT I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
REGISTER SUPPORT FOR A
COMMUNITY CENTER POLICY LINK
OUTWARD BOUND ADVENTURES. ALL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
pREMEMBER STRANICA ON BEHALF OF
THE STORE WITH OUT TOWARDS THE
PARKS NOW COALITION CALIFORNIA
TROUT CALIFORNIA RELEASED AN
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RECALL MONSTER TO NOT A WITH
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND WE'VE
BEEN BUILDING AND DESIGN PARKS
AND PARKS WERE PLACES IN
CALIFORNIA FOR FORTY YEARS AND
NOW HARPER HOW FAR BEHIND WE
ARE AND ADDRESSING THAT.
DISPARITY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR KIM DELFINO
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY. THANK YOU RIGHT
GOOD EVENING CAUTION THURMOND
ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY OPEN STATE THAT'S
ALREADY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO ALL ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY TWO ZERO ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I DON'T
HAVE ANYONE REGISTERED TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TO POSE
ALASKA PERCENT ANYONE IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM. TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE. AND WE'LL GO FROM
THERE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES- MODERATOR. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. LINE
ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE ONE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'LL- ASK
OF THE BODY IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THE
AUTHOR. I BELIEVE WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ALREADY ON
THE FLOOR. CASEY NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS PROJECT CLOSE SPOT
THE ASTRONAUT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MUCH OF DECEMBER DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION TO.
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS EDUARDO GARCIA
HI EDUARDO GARCIA HI DOLLY.
DOLLY NOW BEEN IT. THE BENNETT
I BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA HI KALRA THANK
KALRA AYE LEVINE LEVINE AYE
MERE SUJI NORMAN RUBIO RUBIO
AYE SALAS SALAS I SMITH SMITH
NOVIA PADURA VIA PADILLA I WARD.
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON WE HAVE OUR
FINAL BILL OF THE EVENING AND-
COLLEAGUE CHAIR TRANSPORTATIONS
HERE. TO PRESENT A. B. FOURTEEN
THIRTY FOUR. FIRST I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL. LAST WEEK GOVERNOR NEWSOM
DECLARED A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
OF A FOR A DRAFT OF EMERGENCY
FOR MENDOCINO AND SONOMA
COUNTIES DUE TO THE DROUGHT. IN
THE RUSSIAN RIVER WATERSHED
LAST MONTH FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES I
DON'T SUGGEST MENTAL
INSTITUTIONAL STATE WATER
PROJECT ALLOCATION FOR THE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE WATER YEAR.
THE DEPARTMENT NOW EXPECTS TO
DELIVER FIVE PERCENT. THE
REQUESTED SUPPLIES THIS YEAR
DOWN FROM THE INITIAL
ALLOCATION OF 10% AN OUNCE IN
DECEMBER. ALSO IN MARCH THE US
BUREAU OF RECLAMATION ANNOUNCED
THAT BASED ON ITS PROJECTIONS
IT MIGHT DECLARE AN OFFICIAL
SHORTAGE ON THE COLORADO RIVER
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY.
THREATENING ONE SUPPLY OF WATER
THAT CALIFORNIA DEPENDS ON.
MEMBERS WERE ENTERING ANOTHER
DROUGHT. DURING PASSED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WILL CALL
ON ALL WATER AGENCIES TO CUT
BACK ON THEIR WATER USAGE BY A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE EVERYONE CUT
BACK 20% EVERYONE CUT BACK
THIRTY PERCENT. WELL IF YOU'RE
IN THE AREA WE ARE ALREADY
CONSERVATIONS A WAY OF LIFE
WE'RE ALREADY YOU'RE STRETCHING
EVERY DROP OF WATER. THIS CAN
BE ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO ACHIEVE.
AND MANY WATER AGENCIES HAVE
INVESTED HEAVILY. IN THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS AND WATER
EFFICIENCY TO MAKE SURE. THAT
THEY ARE USING AS LITTLE WATER
AS POSSIBLE AND USING THE
NEWEST TECHNOLOGY FOR- FOR
CONSERVATION. AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AFTER WORKING FOR TWO
YEARS ON THESE BILLS. THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. AND SB SIX OH SIX
WHICH ESTABLISHED NEW WALK LONG
TERM WATER EFFICIENCY GOALS.
WITH THE METHODOLOGY FOR
SETTING WATER USE TARGETS
THAT'S CUSTOMIZED TO EACH
AGENCY. TAKING ADVANTAGE OF NEW
DATA AND TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCEMENTS. THE CUSTOMIZED
TARGETS ARE BASED ON THREE
STANDARDS. THE INDOOR STANDARDS
THAT ARE SET BY THE
LEGISLATURE. THE OUTER STANDARD
WITH THE LEGISLATURE DIRECTED
IF YOU ARE TO DEVELOP AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO BE ADOPTED
BY THE STATE BOARD. AND A WATER
LOSS STANDARD THAT'S BEING
DEVELOPED BY THE STATE BOARD.
THE STANDARDS DO NOT APPLY TO
INDIVIDUAL HOUSEHOLDS. AND
WATER AGENCIES DON'T EVEN HAVE
TO MEET EACH STANDARD THEY JUST
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH AN OVERALL
TARGET. THIS PROVIDES
SIGNIFICANT FLEXIBILITY IN
WHOLE WATER AGENCY MEETS ITS
TARGET IF THEY'RE OVER THEIR
TARGET WATER BUDGET. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE DIDN'T
HAVE ADEQUATE DATA ON INTER
WATER USED TO ESTABLISH A
STANDARD IN THAT ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION. SO THE BILL
INTRICATE. INCLUDED A PLACE
HOLD NUMBER. AND THOSE NUMBER
AND THEN WE DIRECTED D. W. R.
THE STATE FOR TO STUDY. INDOOR
WATER USE AND REPORT BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE IN JANUARY OF
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. A
JOINT RECOMMENDATION FOR WATER
USE THAT BECAUSE OF CODE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE. SOME OF THE
FOLKS THAT WORK WAS DELAYED. AT
A DRAFT REPORT WAS RELEASED
JUST LAST THURSDAY AND THE
STATE IS NOW TAKING PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE DRAFT UNTIL MAY
THIRTEENTH. THEY HOPE TO
COMPLETE A FINAL REPORT BY THE
END OF JUNE. CURRENTLY OVER 75%
OF WATER AGENCIES ARE ALREADY
DOING BETTER. THAN THE FIFTY
FIVE G. P. PCT D. W. R. STATED
THAT THE CURRENT AVERAGE IS
TWENTY ONE. THREE FIFTY ONE AND
THE MEDIAN IS FORTY EIGHT. AT
G. P. CD BASED ON MONTHLY DATA
REPORTED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN TO TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND. TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. THE DRAFT EMENDATIONS
FOR. DO P. OR FOUR. FOR TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY WHICH IS NO
CHANGE. FORTY SEVEN FOR TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE. AND FORTY
TWO FOR TWO THOUSAND THIRTY. I
INTRODUCED AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
FOUR TO UPDATE THE INDOOR
RESIDENTIAL WATER USE STANDARD
TO VALUES THAT MORE
APPROPRIATELY REFLECT CURRENT
PRACTICES AND TRENDS FOR INDOOR
RESIDENTIAL. WATER USE IN
CALIFORNIA. NOW IT'S NOT OUR
INTENT TO INTRODUCE NUMBERS
THAT ARE NOT ACHIEVABLE OR
STRETCH GOALS FOR WATER
AGENCIES. REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE SETS THE
STANDARD AT INDOOR WATER USE IS
DECLINING ALREADY. DUE TO
IMPROVEMENTS IN TECHNOLOGY
REPLACEMENT OF OLD WATER
FIXTURES AND A HIGHER COST OF
WATER TO WATER USERS. SO WHY
NOW. THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
LEGISLATION ASK FOR THE
RECOMMENDATION SO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD REVISIT THE
STANDARDS BEFORE THE STATE
WATER BOARD BEGINS THE PROCESS
OF SETTING THE AGENCY'S OVERALL
WATER TARGETS IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO. IN ADDITION SETTING
THE INDOOR STANDARDS INFORMS
THE PROCESS OF D. W. R. SAID IN
THE OUTDOOR STANDARDS. IF WE
PUT OFF UPDATING THE UNDERSTAND
OR TO NEXT YEAR THE STATE MAY
ALSO NEED TO REVISIT THE
OUTDOOR STANDARDS. WHICH COULD
THEN LEAD TO ANOTHER EIGHTEEN
MONTH RULE MAKING BY OUR STATE
BOARD. THE CURRENT NUMBERS FOR
THE INTEREST AND IN THE BILL OR
PLACEHOLDER NUMBERS ALSO AND
THAT'S IMPORTANT. IT'S OUR
INTENT TO FOLLOW THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS AND TO
AMEND THE BILL IN ACCORDING AND
ACCORDING TO THE AGENCY'S FINAL
RECOMMENDATIONS. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT THIS EVENING OR BARBARA
AMERO DEPUTY MAYOR OF THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES. AND HEATHER
COOLEY WITH THE PACIFIC
INSTITUTE IN OAKLAND. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I
VOTED WE PLEDGE TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
ACHIEVABLE FOR EVERYBODY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ARE CITY
WITNESSES. UP BEGIN THEIR
TESTIMONY. HI THIS IS HEATHER
COOLEY AND DIRECTOR OF RESEARCH
WITH THE- INSTITUTE AND I'M
SPEAKING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR. THE STATE
MADE A COMMITMENT TO SCIENCE AT
THAT WATER EFFICIENCY STANDARDS
IN AB FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT AND
THAT'S BECAUSE THAT. AT THE
TIME LIMITED DATA WERE
AVAILABLE ON INDOOR WATER USE
AND FIFTY FIVE G. PPP THE
COLLECTED AT THE PLACE HOLDER.
WE NOW KNOW THAT FIFTY FIVE IF
YOU HIGH. CONTRAST STUDY
RELEASED BY D. W. AREN'T STATE
STATE WATER BOARD CONFIRMED
THAT CURRENT RESIDENTIAL INDOOR
WATER USE IN CALIFORNIA. THE
FIFTY ONE GALLON PER PERSON PER
DAY. WE ALSO KNOW INDOOR THAT.
AS OLD FIND COULDN'T PICTURE
ARE REFER WITH EFFICIENT MODEL.
SEVERAL STUDIES INCLUDING
RECENT PACIFIC INSTITUTE
ANALYSES ESTIMATE INDOOR USAGE
FOR HOME MEETING CURRENT
STANDARDS WOULD BE ABOUT THIRTY
FIVE GALLONS PER PERSON PER
DAY. THIS IS LARGELY DUE TO
STANDARDS AND CODES FOR
APPLIANCES AND FIXTURES IN NEW
AND EXISTING HOME. SOME RAISE
CONCERNS THAT REDUCING THE AND
OUR STANDARD WOULD HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. HOWEVER THE
DRAFT STUDY RELEASED LAST WEEK
FOUND THAT LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLD
USING LESS WATER AND HIGHER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. SOME ALSO
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT THE
EFFECT ON RECYCLED WATER. THE
FRAMEWORK PROVIDES SEX
FLEXIBILITY TO ATTRACT THE
CONCERNED BUT THE KEY POINT IS
TO RECOGNIZE THAT INDOOR FOR
CAPITA USE IS DECLINING DUE TO
STANDARDS AND CODES AND IT'S
CRITICAL COMMUNITIES RECOGNIZE
THIS TREND. SO THAT THE RIGHT
SIZE RECYCLED WATER INVESTMENTS
TO ABORT THE NFC JERRY KAUFMAN
STRANDED OUT AT. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IF YOU
ARE IS CAñADA TO ENGAGE STATE
AND FINALIZING THE IN YOUR
WATER USE REPORT IN A TIMELY
MANNER. TO ENSURE THAT BOTH THE
INDOOR AND OUTDOOR STANDARDS
ARE BASED ON SCIENCE. AT
FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE IS
URGENTLY NEEDED THIS YEAR. I
ASKED THE SUPPORT PATH PASSAGE
OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR WITH
THE AMENDMENT COULD COMMITMENTS
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THE NEXT WITNESS.
NOT TO BE
BARBARA AMERO YES JUST FOR THE
OPERATOR MAYBE. CURRENTLY DID
NOT SEE THEM DIALED IN- BARBER
MERYL IF YOU ARE ONLINE PLEASE
PRESS STAR ZERO SO I CAN OPEN
YOUR LINE. THEY ARE CURRENTLY
NOT DIALED IN OVER THE PHONE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON
AND- SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK THAT'S IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM. IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE. ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE. AND THAT WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES- NAME
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT
POSITION. IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
OVER TO LINE TWO HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS CAITLYN COLUSA ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COULD KEEPER
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT. TO THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT ONE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
KAREN MEMBERS WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO COMMITTEE WATER
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL I
WANTED OPENING TERRY. THIRTY
MEMBER RACY QUINN WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR. THANK YOU
RIGHT TWO OH EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MARTHA
DAVIS ON THE BOARDS OF THE MONO
LAKE MEAD IT MODEL LIKE
COMMITTEE SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI FOURTEEN
THIRTY FOUR. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RYAN TO ALL FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY TWO ZERO FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
WILL TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
I DON'T HAVE OR DO I HAVE TO
INDIVIDUALS REGISTERED TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DANIEL HI CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION. REPRESENTING MORE
THAN FIFTY PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SERVER WATER TO OVER 75% OF
CALIFORNIANS WE'RE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED AT FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR
I'M SEEING YOU A WITH PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THE FINAL PACKAGE
THAT WITH THE MAKING
CONSERVATION A WAY OF LIFE
LEGISLATION WHICH INCLUDED. AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THE ROAD TO
THE PASSAGE OF THIS- PASSAGE OF
THIS PACKAGE WITH LONG COMPLEX
AND INVOLVED A LARGE NUMBER OF
LEGISLATORS AND STAKEHOLDERS
INTERESTED IN WATER USE
EFFICIENCY. THE LANGUAGE ABOUT
INDOOR WATER USE WITH CONCISE
BUT THE SUBJECT OF INTENSE
NEGOTIATIONS. AT THE END OF
THIS PROCESS WHAT YOU SEE AN
EXISTING STATUTE WITH THE
AGREEMENT THAT SET OF STANDARDS
WITH SPECIFIC TIMELINES IN A
CRITICAL REQUIREMENTS REPEAT IF
YOU ARE IN THE STATE BOARD TO
CONDUCT THE NECESSARY STUDIES.
AND INVESTIGATIONS. HAVE
POSSIBLY RECOMMEND TO THE
LEGISLATURE STANDARDS THEY MAY
MORE APPROPRIATELY REFLECT BEST
PRACTICES FOR INDOOR
RESIDENTIAL WATER USE. WE ARE
POSTAVY FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR
FOR TWO REASONS FIRST WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED. THAT THE
PROPOSED REVISION. TO YOU DO
READ. THE CODE. AND SAYS. THAT
THE CALL. INCLUDING SCREEN THAT
STANDARD OF FIFTY. GB CD UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. SECOND THE
CHANGES ARBITRARILY CHANGED THE
STATUTE FOR NOT ONLY THE FIFTY
FIVE GP CD BUT THE OTHER
STANDARD. WITHOUT A FINAL
VERSION OF THE REPORT INDEED IF
YOU ARE IN THE BOARD. WE ARE
PLEASED TO SEE THAT THE W. R.
GIVE A PREVIEW OF THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT THEY'RE
JUST THAT ARE PRE LEAD TO THE
DRAFT THAT WE EXPECT TO SEE IN
THE FUTURE. WE APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT YOU HAVE YOU ARE IN
THE WATER BOARD ARE. ASKING FOR
COMMENTS- ON THIS PREVIEW AND
WE WILL DEFINITELY BE BE
PROVIDING FEEDBACK AS WELL BUT
WITHOUT THAT DRAFTED THE
NECESSARY REVISED STAKEHOLDER
INPUT AND THE FINAL VERSION. IT
IS SIMPLY PREMATURE TO ADVANCE.
WE APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN'S COMMENTS TODAY AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HER AND AT ON THIS MEASURE. WE
ARE HERE NOW ABOUT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESSES DAVID PETERSON.
THANK YOU CHAIR GARCIA A MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DAVID PETERSON AND THAT GENERAL
MANAGER UP LOCKED VIRGIN AT
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT MIGHT
AGENCY WHAT AMOUNT BURKE.
RETAIL WATER AGENCIES TO TAKE A
SUPPORT POSITION ON A. B.
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT. BACK IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THAT'S THE
BILL THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. AUTHORED TO ESTABLISH
THE THANK DOOR WATER USE
STANDARD. AT THAT TIME THERE
WERE OVER FORTY WATER AGENCIES
THAT WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL
IT. AT THAT TIME OUT WE FELT
COMFORTABLE SUPPORTING THE BILL
BECAUSE IT WAS BASED ON A DATA
DRIVEN STANDARD PROCESS. AND
THEY WERE BROUGHT OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STAKEHOLDER INPUT. ALTHOUGH
THE BILL WITHOUT WITH FAR
SUPERIOR TO THE PERCENTAGE
REDUCTION APPROACH THAT BUT THE
WAY AT THE TIME. NOW AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR PROPOSES
TO CHANGE AND LOWERED THE
STANDARDS FOR INDOOR WATER USE.
BEFORE CALIFORNIA P. W. R. AT
THIRTY LATEST THEIR REPORT TO
THE PUBLIC YOU KNOW AND BEFORE
THEY'VE RECEIVED FEEDBACK FROM
STAKEHOLDERS. THIS IS REALLY
GOING BACK ON THAT COMMITMENT
BUT THAT WAS MADE IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS OR EIGHTY FIFTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. I SUSPECT THAT THE
INDOOR WATER USE TARGET
PROPOSED BY THIS BILL OR OR
SOMETHING CLOSE TO THEM. MAYBE
COME STANDARD ONE DAY BUT AFTER
THAT THE COMMITTEE UNDER THE
PRODUCT THAT. AND HOLD THE BILL
OVER AT THE TO YOUR BILL. AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR. WERE TO
BE HELD AT THE TO YOUR BILL. IT
COULD BE AMENDED EARLY NEXT
YEAR TO INCORPORATE THE RESULT
OF THE GDPR REPORT AFTER THE
BUT POLITICAL THERE IS THREE
FEET. IF THAT IS DONE I EXPECT
I CAN BE BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE ALONG WITH MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO TALK TO FIND
SUPPORT. MAYBE FOURTEEN THIRTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR I'M SORRY I
WAS TOLD THAT OUR WITNESS IS
ACTUALLY ON THE LINE NOW. WHAT
WITNESS IF YOU'RE THAT IS YOUR
PLEASURE ONE WOULD DO THAT THAT
WAY YOU HAVE YOUR TWO WITNESSES
AND. PLEASE PROCEED. I DO NOT
SEE THEM DIALED IN IF YOU ARE
ON THE LINE PLEASE PRESS STAR
ZERO SO I CAN OPEN YOUR LINE. I
STILL DO NOT SEE THEM DIALED IN
WILL LARA WILL CONTINUE THANK-
WE HAVE- ANYONE IN THE
CONFERENCE ROOM WISHING TO.
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE. AC MILAN WILL
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
OPPOSITION TO A. B. FOURTEEN
THIRTY FOUR. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NINE TWO ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING JAMIE MINOR
OF THE APATHY IN A MARGARITA
WATER DISTRICT IN EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
RESPECTFULLY MUST DEPART THE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
J. CONNECTED WITH ADOPTING
GILBERT ROPES AND SPENT ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
WATER DISTRICT IN RANCHO
CALIFORNIA WATER DISTRICT BOTH
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
ONE SIX ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT'S ALL ALSO ON BEHALF OF
WATER REUSE CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE WHOLE WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT TO ARRIVE AND PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FINANCIAL ONE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE TWO OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE TWO ZERO
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI MY NAME IS
LENOVO AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WATER EFFICIENCY
PARTNERSHIP WE ARE CURRENTLY
NOT TAKING AN OFFICIAL POSITION
ON AT FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR AT
THIS TIME BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS REGARDING THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY AFTER RELATES TO
THE LOWER INDOOR. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO OUR NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE TWO ZERO NINE OF
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
THREE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL I ONE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE ONE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND ONE FOUR
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE THREE
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUYING TO
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
GLENN PARLIAMENTS ACCOUNTING
WATER AUTHORITY I WAS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE REDUCE
STANDARDS- POTENTIAL IMPACT ON
POTABLE REUSE AND RECYCLE WATER
PARK PRODUCTION AND-
REGRETTABLY MUST OPPOSE THE
CALL. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPENING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE DICE AND
ACID THE PUBLIC SAYS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MOVES RECOMMENDED
ACTIONS. THAT A MOTION TO MISS
BENNET. IS OUR SECOND. SECOND
MEMBERS CAR I HAVE PROGRAM YES
WE DID IT- I APPRECIATE. THE
AUTHOR'S- COMMIT TO CONSTANTLY.
NET JOSH AS THE DAY COME IN-
MOVING FOR I'D LIKE TO-
ACTUALLY ASK YOU. TO OF SOME OF
THE COMMENTS ABOUT THIS BEING
PREMATURE AND WHAT I BELIEVE
YOU ARE VERY ARTICULATED ABOUT
WHY WE NEED TO MOVE NOW. BASED
ON THE CALENDAR. YEAH BECAUSE
THEY ALTER STANDARDS ARE ALSO
BEING SAID WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE USE THE MOST ACCURATE
STAND A NUMBERS THAT WE HAVE.
FOR THE INDOOR STANDARDS
BECAUSE OTHERWISE TO MAKE THE
MATH WORK THEY COULD START TO
SOCIALLY THE DIFFERENT
STANDARDS OFF AGAINST EACH
OTHER. SO WE DO HAVE SOME DATA
PULMONARY DATA NOW THAT'S FROM
A COUPLE OF YEARS IN THE MAKING
AND WE THINK THAT IT'S STILL
PRUDENT TO GO AHEAD AND JUST
CONTINUE TO REFINE THAT NUMBER.
AS THE BILL MOVES TO THE
PROCESS. CAN AND IF. AND IF WE
DON'T THEN WE WOULD KNOW WHAT
TO SEE TO SEE OUT WHAT COULD
POTENTIALLY HAVE TO STATE THAT
ARE REALLY BASS ON THE THAT WE
THAT WE KNOW A ARE REAL THANK
YOU MUCH OKAY. GAELIC THE
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS. PLEASE
ALRIGHT JUST FOLLOW UP ON THAT
TO THIS FRIEDMAN UP WELL WHAT
ABOUT THE- YOU KNOW I MEAN I.
OBVIOUSLY I SUPPORT YOUR GOAL
OF A- PROMOTING WATER
CONSERVATION BUT- NORMALLY I
DON'T SEE LIKE THE MUNICIPAL
WATER AGENCIES AS BEING LIKE A-
SUSPECT INTEREST GROUP ARE. YOU
KNOW THAT WHERE I HAVE TO
QUESTION NO. THEIR THEIR
MOTIVES AND SO I'M I'M I'M JUST
YOU KNOW TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING HERE RESPONSIBILITY YEAH
THEY THEY SAY THAT NOT ONLY. DO
WE DO THEY NEED TO. THE UPDATED
NUMBERS BUT THEY NEED THIS
THIS. YOU KNOW VIGOROUS-
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS BEFORE. AND
THAT THAT WAS PART OF THE DEAL
THAT WAS STRUCK WITH THE
PREVIOUS- BILL COULD YOU.
ADDRESS THAT NOW WE'RE AFRAID
THAT IF WE PUT THIS OFF THIS
COULD DELAY THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE NUMBERS FOR UP TO THREE
YEARS. AND WE DO THINK IT'S A
PROCESS BUT WE NEED IT WE THINK
WE NEED TO BEGIN IT NOW. I
WE'RE GOING TO DROUGHT AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
AGENCIES ARE PRACTICING
CONSERVATION AND THAT MEANS
HAVING A STANDARD A TARGET. FOR
EVERYBODY TO WORK ON THAT'S
REALISTIC WE KNOW THAT THE
TARGET THAT WAS IN THE BILL WAS
ACTUALLY- HAD AN AMOUNT OF
WATER THAT WAS LOWER THAN IS
ACTUALLY BEING USED. WITHIN THE
STATE SO IF YOU HAVE A TARGET
THAT'S TOO HIGH THAT'S ALREADY
WERE ALREADY WITHIN YOU'RE
REALLY NOT GOING TO GET ANYBODY
TO MOVE THE ENVELOPE VERY MUCH.
I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN WITH
THE WATER AGENCIES THEY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO SELL THE WATER BUT
THEY NEED TO SELL- AND THEY
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE IN COMPLIANCE BUT- WE
WILL WORK WITH THEM YOU KNOW AS
A PARTY AS WELL. WHO GOT ALMOST
ALL OF THEM IN THE LAST TIME TO
GO FROM SLIDING OUT THE DOOR IN
OPPOSITION TO SIXTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. TO BE MOST OF THEM
EITHER BEING IN FAVOR OF IT OR
BEING NEUTRAL ON THE BILL AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THEM. MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU.
NO QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT DOES
NOT HAVE A TO PASS- TO
APPROPRIATIONS THEY JUST WANT
TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT YOU KNOW
WE ALSO HEARD A LOT FROM THE
STAKEHOLDERS- THAT SPOKE TODAY
BUT ONE OF THINGS I THINK WOULD
BE A GOOD- POLICY. KIND OF
APPROACH. WOULD BE T
POTENTIALLY BRINGS BILL BACK
ONCE TERE'S SOME MORE
SENSITIVE INFORMATION. COMING
FROM THE REPORT. IN ORDER FOR
THIS COMMITTEE AND ITS MEMBERS
TO HAVE A LITTLE MORE.
DELIBERATION ON IT AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO HAVE SOME
IMPORTANT SO WE DO HAVE A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. AND OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF WAS COULD BE
WORKING CLOSELY. WITH THEIR
TEAM AND AT THE RIGHT MOMENT-
BRING THE BILL BACK FOR HEARING
AND HAVING SOME ADDITIONAL
INPUT I THINK WOULD BE A GOOD
PRACTICE FOR US. GIVEN THE
TIMING- OF THE BILL AND THE
LACK OF INFORMATION THAT WE'LL
WAIT. IN ORDER TO MAKE A MUCH
MORE SUBSTANTIVE A POLICY
DECISION. SO- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. A DEAL SITE YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT TO DO THAT WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE AFFECTED AGENCIES.
HAVE SOMETHING THAT THEY FEEL
IS WORKABLE A TARGET THAT MAKES
SENSE THAT GOES PUSH AGENCIES
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN AS GOOD WITH
CONSERVATION TO KIND OF GET
WITH THE PROGRAM TO MAKE THE
INVESTMENTS. IN THE REPAIRS ARE
THAT THEY NEED TO HAVE THE
RIGHT TECHNOLOGY THAT THEY WORK
ON THEIR OWN WEEKS AND THEIR
SYSTEM PROFICIENCY WITHIN THEIR
SYSTEMS THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN THE
GOAL. IT'S NOT PUNITIVE IT'S
ABOUT EVERYBODY IN THE STATE
RECOGNIZING THAT WE ALL RISE OR
FALL TOGETHER WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE WATER WHEN WE
NEED IT THE MOST AND THAT MEANS
INVESTING IN. IN NOT JUST
CONSERVATION BUT INEFFICIENCY
IT'S- IT'S REALLY ABOUT TRYING
TO PUSH EVERYONE TO BE AS
EFFICIENT AS WE CAN BE AND WE
ALL HAVE TO BE ON THE SAME PAGE
WITH THAT AND THAT'S WHAT
THESE. THESE MEASURES HAVE BEEN
ABOUT FOR US FOR THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT AND WE ABSOLUTELY WILL.
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH EVERYBODY
ON THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO PATRICK. FROM
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND.
FOR ROLL CALL. THE MOTION IS
THE PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA HI EDUARDO
GARCIA HI DOLLY. DOLLY NO
BENNETT. BENNETT I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO FRIEDMAN THANK
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I KALRA. ALL
RIGHT I LEVINE LEVINE I'M
MURATSUCHI. MURATSUCHI NOT
VOTING WHEN RUBIO RUBIO NOT
VOTING SALAS. SMITH SMITH NO BE
ABLE TO DO IT WE HAVE TO DO IT
NOW WARD. WARD I. I BELIEVE
FROM EVERYONE IS HERE. BUT- WE
DO HAVE. OTHER BILLS TO- AT
VOTES WILL KEEP AN OPEN IN THE
CASE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
EVERYONE HERE FOR THIS VOTE-
AND- ALONG THE WAY TO THE TOP
THANK YOU- AS- SUMMER FRIEDMAN.
I BELIEVE THAT WAS SEVEN VOTE
SO WE HAVE TO KEEP IT OPEN TO
SEE IF THERE'S GOING TO BE
ANYONE ELSE ADDED ON. WE'LL GO
TO THE TOP WITH THOSE WHO NEED
TO. ADD ON TO. BILLS WE HAD
SOME FOLKS COME IN LATE- IF YOU.
NEED TO ADD ON WILL GO TO THE
KALRA BILL. GOOD JOB THANK YOU
SIR FULL SCHOOL START AT THE
TOP AND WORK OUR WAY DOWN FOR
THOSE WHO NEED TO ADD ON. WE'LL
START WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ABSENT MEMBERS FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA I KALRA KALRA
AYE MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I
KNOW IN. WARD. SO I FOUND. I'M
SORRY I KNOW WHEN I. RIGHT MORE
WORD I. I AM ONE AB THIRTY.
ABSENT MEMBERS MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I KNOW WHEN. NO AND
NO. WARD WORD I. ARE YOU YOU
THAT WOULD THE ONE YOU. I DON'T
KNOW TWO B. TH FIVE ZERO.
ABSENT BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I KNOW WHEN AND I
SALAS SALAS I WARD WORD I. YOU
ARE HAVE YOU IS AND I. SH ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB. SEVEN FIVE
FOUR. ABSENT MEMBERS FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA. CRISTINA
GARCIA I KALRA. KALRA NOT
VOTING LEVINE SORRY YOU ALREADY
VOTED. SUJI MURATSUCHI NOW NO
WHEN I WARD WARD NOW. I HAVE
USER NINE. FOR AND- ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB NINE SEVEN NINE ABSENT
MEMBERS BENNETT. BIGELOW
BIGELOW NOW FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN
NOT VOTING CRISTINA GARCIA. AB
NINE SEVEN NINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER- CRISTINA GARCIA I.
KALRA KALRA I MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI AYE NEWMAN. NO AND
NO SALAS. SALAS KNOWN WARD WORD
I. BENNETT I. THANK YOU. THE
ITEM NUMBER. ELEVEN EIGHTY
ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR ABSENT
MEMBERS BIGELOW. BIGELOW I
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA I KALRA
KALRA I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I
NEWMAN. WHEN I SALAS SALAS I
WARD WORD I. THE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE
ABSENT MEMBERS BIGELOW. BIGELOW
NOW FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I KALRA KALRA AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I KNOW WHEN. NO I
KNOW. SALAS IT IS. SOUTH SIDE
WARD WARD I. THIS ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
FOUR. ABSENT MEMBERS KNOW WHEN.
NO I KNOW. ADAM NUMBER SIXTEEN
AB. FIFTEEN TWELVE. ABSENT
MEMBERS BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOW
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA
GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA I'D
KALRA KALRA I MURATSUCHI. I'M
SERVICES- A. B. FIFTEEN TWELVE
I AM SIXTEEN. MERCI GI WHEN NO
SALAS SALAS I WARD OR. NINE
IT'S A FAIR. I WOULD LIKE TO.
GIVE A COURTESY VOTE OR. THREE-
I NEED WORKING THIRTY FOUR. AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY FOUR MURATSUCHI
HI. FIVE WHERE'S THE CHEAT I
SALAS NOW.